two hello everybody it is Wednesday
off the rails you know what it is May
17th okay let's go
sponsored today by expressvpn thank you
so much we love them
well we've got quite a show here and you
know okay all right
[Music]
oh
wow
[Music]
what was the original was that an
original music uh song no that was a
Nook uh oh that was a Nookie yeah I did
it all for the anoki sure yeah that was
a Take Me Home Country Road and uh oh I
pitched him up
oh wow well done thank you well welcome
everybody
skinny Ethan here
I look I feel that I look skinnier I'm
seeing myself in the previewer
definitely I'm feeling it finally girly
you do you've been
I've been I promise slay
it's nice though oh I got all these
Fitness guys apologizing to me now
I finally respect him again
yeah we gotta actually if you stack up
this one against all the other shows
we've done this one that we've got here
today is going to stack up
fairly well
right in the middle of the road it's a
pretty good one okay it's okay
it's okay well I'll tell you what we've
got planned Sam Samantha if I may
actually
may I
oh
my whole government
your government name
hey so actually Sam is a couple of
points of contention so first of all
actually three points of contention I
have with you Sam today okay well so
first of all
fika fish as you guys know Soom strowman
the most disgusting stinky vile [__] out
of Sweden that we've eaten a few times
on the show
it's been discontinued
no longer making it because of
overfishing thank god wow this is the
not enough herring in the sea cool
you know I never thought I'd say this
but overfishing good
[Music]
I mean less fee less Zoom strowman
that's a dub for Humanity
but we have like we had like two or
three of the last cans on Earth which we
had to go through Extreme Measures to
gather
Sam has taken upon herself because we've
eaten it so many times disgustingly but
we said you know let's prepare it the
traditional way that the swedes do
because love is always telling us no you
got to do it this way you got to open it
under water you got to open it outside
you gotta boil the fish and then put it
on whatever you know you've got money
and uh so we said okay let's try to make
this [__] delicious because apparently
some of y'all out there like this [__]
so that's what Sam's done how many
dishes have you prepared for us I've
prepared it four ways
four ways nice
good for you
so that's the first thing we're going to
be doing and that's exciting I guess
[Applause]
the second one is that there was a
I saw this video
and I sent it to the Gang
because I thought it was so incredible
and then Sam starts calling me out
where is this [__] video where what
number is it here it is this man
check this out there's been a whole
debate in the office about is this real
or fake oh I guess I won't play the
music but
so this man is obviously a pizza dough
uh
uh I mean he's the best in the world
who does that
it floats that [__] floats
and then well here's the craziest part
that
you know
now
I don't know if it's real or fake but I
I swear to God I'm learning towards real
and then but the problem is then Sam
goes oh it's definitely fake I says well
you can do that with the Frisbee you can
do that
she goes a Frisbee's not a boomerang
says no you can do that so she's
doubting if it's even possible that is
so fake Ethan when he throws it and it
comes back that is so fake okay hold on
first of all Sam says you can't even do
that with the Frisbee that's ridiculous
Are you standing behind that still I I
don't think you can do that with a
frisbee cheese man
I can't believe you would say that I
would love to be proved wrong yep I I
think you guys never been here can be
done with the Frisbee I don't think you
can show us today okay well then that's
the second part like that's what I'm
saying the third part I definitely can
do this
I don't know if I can I'm sorry
how many times you guys gonna doubt my
athleticism
every time you guys stepped up to me as
an athlete I have I told you when you
got here we were talking about this that
I actually believe in you and with this
one thank you I'm stepping up to you you
have the credentials you can hear a dad
experience you wear shorts with socks
and slides okay this is he has all the
frizzy predictions and he went to Santa
Cruz and he went to Santa Cruz most
importantly Sam goes oh I played I
played uh Ultimate Frisbee once or twice
I said I went to you USC you as UCSC
well you're wrong a lot today
yeah ultimate Frisbee's the it's the
national sport in that City
the Nationals
I am the office kind of a doctor I
always doubt [__] always to like a
annoying extent but I think this is real
and I think it's possible with a frisbee
I think it's possible with a doe
I'm totally with you oh my God okay
that's big he's all in yeah that's big
so the the only problem here is
obviously we have a pretty tall roof
here but not that tall what do you think
that's like 20 feet maybe I mean you
need to you need to throw it pretty high
but I'm confident that I can at least
demonstrate
that it goes up and comes back down it
won't be perfect with this low roof
situation
[Music]
of cement posting but I I can
demonstrate it too if we go outside I
could do it easily
easily yeah first try easily I don't
understand how you can even doubt that
right not doubting just go to YouTube
and type I mean what the hell dude we're
on YouTube this is this is the YouTube
video you look up we're about to make it
but you know what I'm what do you think
is fake about this go ahead Sam
about the dough yeah about the Doughboy
doesn't do that
if you you're telling me if you throw
pizza dough it will Boomerang back to
you if it's light enough
I don't no I don't think that that's
real because obvi clearly the dough he
he's a master at creating this really
thin light dough
and at a certain point Sam I don't know
if you know anything about air
resistance and velocity and weight
you know about your resistance
but like look how it Glides down do you
think that's fake
like when he Glides it here is it all
fake or this part real
real I think when he's holding it and
doing his little tricks that is real so
okay Rose it though
if this man happening and it's not
that's not not real if this man can
create a gliding pizza right there
before your eyes he can do the Frisbee
trick it's clearly light enough to float
down
yeah this is not pizza by the way I
don't think
maybe like a crazy story oh maybe you're
right actually does that change now that
might change things if I'm not pizza
dough it's dough what does it mean like
it depends on what kind
almond flour dough that looks like flour
wait
that's flour dude he tosses that thing
like Captain America's shield yeah dude
that guy he's the man
dude this guy's the man good [__] when
he's doing that I don't think the people
in the back are following the pizza
though
that's that's what I was gonna say is
when he catches it they don't really
react huh
like if I saw that [__] I'd be like pull
me with the bowl cut back there oh
there's his head turned I don't know
okay first of all I don't know how long
they've been watching him but
I mean they do react they're loving it
the first time I saw that I was like oh
my God magic if that's real me too I
sent it to you guys
and it happened in front of them I was
watching it on tick tock
I don't know what to tell you guys I
think you're living in a and you're
living in denial I think it's a great
men like this exist you think it's a
crazy I think it's a crepe okay does
that change your analysis
um Crepes fly like yeah grapes can fly
but people oh interesting it changes a
little bit because a crepe is a lot is
less elastic than Doe
you think dough would separate I don't
believe it if you if you were to fling
down like that it would stretch the
whole the whole shape listen
you've never flung
look you're in a world where dough can
fly or it can't fly I don't know why
you're why you're hedging your
statements now
fly
you say dough cannot fly Sam but Sam now
says dough can fly a crepe might be able
to fly though can fly you said
show me the wings well yeah but not like
that
but now that you know when pizza's like
thrown up and like when like when he's
holding it when it's around him that is
possible with dough I think he has no
pizza experience yeah yeah you might
have crepe experience
if it is fake it's one of those videos
where like why would they fake that
and that's a good point the people's
heads don't even follow they're not even
looking
they don't even follow when the dove
flies Okay wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong
wrong wrong wrong wrong
orb that like wrong when he tosses it
and it stays on the screen but I wonder
what that means hold on I'd like to look
at that one more time hold on hold on
hold on there's a man here on the right
you can't see many faces because the
camera pans so fast but watch this guy
in the bottom right
where's his head where's his head look
at the people in back this old lady is
looking up what's she looking at
is she in on it too wrong look at her
look at her look at the boy on the bike
what is he a plant I can't see the boy
on the bike I know what you're I can
he's looking up is he is there even a
person on that bike
[Laughter]
that little boy is on the bike and he's
looking up at the time of his life okay
what about this lady this lady this guy
where are they looking this guy right
here everybody's looking at the pizza
my eyes on though because he was looking
to the side and then he follows back so
I don't know and he does seem to be
watching there are smiles
I do not often agree with things being
real about may I introduce another proof
uh that it's real go ahead oh we have
some more evidence I don't go out and
like tarnish my repetition saying stuff
is real right if I'm not sure you're the
ultimate hater
I'm the ultimate hater and this video
that I just sent in the Discord kinda in
my opinion proves that this is a thing
this is your American mindset now you're
optimistic
this is an art right I don't know what
country June does anyone know what
country this takes place in no it looks
like Chinese I think this is a China an
ancient Chinese art of uh
of uh pastry flinging yeah and I agree
with Samus Prime
that man just did it dude there's like a
whole ass
group of people who are just throwing
Christmas an ancient Chinese are foreign
Crepes like there ain't no tomorrow
right you go and you see this on any
Street Corner in China people just
tossing Crepes yeah
we're also just kind of you know in like
uh you know like Crouching Tiger like
how they float like they're on wires or
whatever absolutely they're just like
dancing acrobatically through the
streets tossing pizza around absolutely
it's in the ancient text
yeah it's definitely a crepe though
but uh
what's going on in his face what is he
wearing
wait what's going on with this guy's
face because he's like able to look
he can like look so it's not a full-on
mask oh I'm being told this is actual
that's his actual face
what the [__]
laughs
so Sam I don't know
we can settle the Frisbee part right now
but okay if you think a crepe dough can
do this then you're admitting a crispy
condition I don't know I a frisbee might
be able to do it I don't think you can
do it oh I see so you're you're every
you're moving the goal post every time I
ask flight shift oh okay so well
[Music]
let me find you uh frisbee
frisbee uh Boomerang I don't know how
else to say but you'll see yeah well you
look there's videos out there I thought
you were gonna demonstrate for it well
because Sam was saying first of all it's
not possible I thought you knew how to
do it I can do it chill the [__] out
damn I don't know I feel like you
haven't gotten up yet you know I went
out on a limb and said I believed in you
Ethan and now you kind of
here I'm gonna be pulling back a little
bit
no but just look what this guy can do
you see how far he chucked that
coming right back to him
bam and and you know
you could see that in every Park in
America
now can I do it absolutely it's so easy
you could do it you want me to try to do
it right here in this low-ass roof
let's take a poll first I want to know
if the people think
if it's real or not it's the p is the
doe flinging real or fake
also when I came in Cameron was like yo
it's fake dude so I I took a lot of heat
here for for backing up my Doughboy I'm
I'm starting to change my mind I think
okay yeah did you see that heat I
dropped the second angle and the um
Discord there this is like who shot JFK
the second angle from the same guy
oh [__] video completely oh [__] there
was more than one
video taken
but then that would make it like
impossible wow this is this is that's
compelling Maybe
he did it again that was a difference
that's two two more cries also to fake
it from two different angles would be
nuts wow good for him he's very talented
then
oh talented it's crazy thank you Cameron
he is flinging Doe
that man's flinging though
there is okay so let's do a pull real
fast and then I'll demonstrate my skill
pulls up uh it's about 75 real about a
quarter of the audience is still
doubting though I'm actually surprised
that there's still a quarter of you
Dalton
real
the real question is does it affect the
taste although people are saying it's a
bad pull
that's that's on you
you know what I got picked up personally
I got hit with my first bad poll on
Tuesday good but they were right
it could always be clear
that being said this one's pretty clear
I don't know what how this one seems
like a perfect pool is it definitely in
real or fake real fake I mean I don't
know how you could mistake that
amazing pull all right let's do it
let's see what I want to do ready yeah
all right
all right I'm stepping into the
demonstration tank where I'll be
throwing a frisbee
okay they are walking over Dan is not
camera operation
be your ball boy they can hear me
okay so I gotta find again you can see
I'm inside so it's not
but basically the strategy is you know
I'm gonna try to throw it up for to that
corner the height corner there if you're
just enough space
return you saw how far that guy bombed
it but what I'm hoping to demonstrate
here today to silence the haters is that
I can it will return back to me a little
bit it will change direction
okay
so with all that being said I'm in my
shorts I'm in my sandals I'm in my socks
as Dan noted
I'll try again but you it was gone
okay so we'll go one more time
you can't really do it in here
it's a tiny roof here let me try it like
you see it's coming back
I'll go outside if you need me to Sam
it tease me right
there it is it comes back I mean I don't
know yeah okay in English now you guys
are just watching two grown men play
Frisbee inside all right let's see
you see it I mean it's coming back is it
not coming back
it's coming back that way nope
yeah did I did I pass Dan you tell me
yeah just like the man with the dough
don't come back oh my God all right no
here we go Chad's saying he looks scary
or you want to get from this angle dad
it needs to go really high the point is
the height that makes it reverse motion
[__] are you sure
you have fun
oh okay
okay dude
if could I do that
bring it here
nope
also a [__] heater at you boy I'll
catch it I don't want to hurt you
I could throw it that hard don't hit
love are you serious no no no it will
hurt you it'll hurt you
I got insurance you pay my health
insurance I don't I can't do it you put
on a glove I'm telling you it's gonna be
a heater bro just do it just do it
get it up
[Music]
dude
you didn't want to catch that look at
that though come here again
thank you
yeah you don't want to catch that God
damn it's indented you guys
thank you Cameron thank you
you know I thought I'd come back a
little bit come on
come on I gotta prove my credentials
here
right
we have dough as well oh yeah let's try
it with the dough now
but again if I can't deal with the bring
up the dough bring out the dough
I'm doing it with the dough
it's not a people are saying it's about
the wind it's not about the wind it's
about the
the angle of attack
can we even go outside
it wouldn't really
yeah we don't hit our car if we go
outside I don't think we can go outside
okay bringing out the dough thank you
girl
so this is pizza dough as so I agree
with you Sam it's not pizza dough this
is too heavy yeah I think it
grape is made from a batter not a dough
huh what's the difference
batter is like thinner than dough
batter and also the thing though you can
see the
um the big round thing in front of him I
think is the like the crepe Grill that's
for sure no it's a crepe yeah it is for
sure crepe can I get a roller or
something
roll it this [__] about to fly I don't
give a [__]
some flour too
I'm gonna make this fly right now roll
it
roll it
game Stars the edge of his seat always
ready yeah this is too uh and in the
world
it's too sticky
a lint roller okay a lint roller
come get a shot of this guys yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah there we go thank
you
vodka with natural flavors
okay but you guys can you get a shot of
this all different flavors I think I
need flour to roll this properly
otherwise it's just gonna stick you know
do we have flour
someone in chess said what is this
podcast about it's about making memories
it's about nothing in the Seinfeld uh
style I cannot flatten this [__]
dough just
just such
well let me try the lint roller at least
but look how look how sticky it is it
just shrinks
it's like
it's like your penis in the cold water
thanks
well I'll tell you one thing there ain't
gonna be no lint on it
that's some clean dough right there I'll
tell you what mate ain't never seen
dough that clean before mm-hmm
it's like you're playing with Play-Doh
you're making no progress it's just I
don't know there is progress there is I
see it okay I see it
I'll tell you what boy I ain't letting
the dough that flat and that clean
let them cook
there's progress
stop shrinking though damn what's with
this [__] Doe
Ethan it might be easier if you were to
pick it up and go around the edge like
this
I think so yeah and maybe if you did
like an Italian accent it might help too
fermented
spin it I'm not very good at that
back time not good at it I have no
Talent I've never done game
he has no pizza experience that's true
[__] dude I think I made it smaller all
right let's try this ready
it's just a rock
it's just a it's just a it's just a ball
of dough
all right ready ready
to the real
I'm sorry we're back all right ready cam
yes
I'm trying to get it to stick to the
roof
yeah
[Music]
I came back
well somehow
oh Evie's got another one oh yeah that
one looks good thanks baby
Loki came back to you yeah I'm good
okay ready this is the one
forget about it huh
[Applause]
there's some dough on the roof
all right here comes one here comes a
heater to your wall
that was a good throw
or yeah [__] up this wall bro
oh no no don't do it
all right it's show AP
K oh [__]
oh [__] you're using the Jesus I know
the spirit of Jesus but you really got
it holy [__]
that'll come down by the end of the show
okay yeah no it's like wrapped around
the table
that's actually impressive huh I know
dude perfect baby
[Applause]
incredible things happen when I
when I pick up a sport
the doe did fly the doe didn't come down
the don't ever came down they say what
must go up must come down not here not
my world
you know I read a comment once that this
is the show is just iCarly for adults
and that's oh yeah I don't know
I don't know what that means to be
honest you were talking older Millennial
Nickelodeon this is some younger yeah I
mean I've never what is iCarly about uh
is a web show where they did silly [__]
like a web show one of my favorites like
our podcast yeah it's like our podcast
we did like yeah it was two two best
friends and their other friend who did
camera oh it's like a YouTube show in
their show they had a show the show is
about them doing a show
on the internet yeah
yeah that's us dude and it's literally
just like this
so good dude Perfect's [__] crying
right now and written by Dan Schneider
mm-hmm
Dude Perfect is literally about their
fingers trembing as they're on the
delete channel button
okay that was fun uh then the other the
next thing I gotta ask you about Sam
throw on the topic
can we do one more who has the power to
do a poll
yeah can you just do can Ethan frisbee
can anything frisbee boomerang
no obviously I'm not you know I can't
show my full strength here today
as we are concealed into a finite space
just send a video when you go home maybe
okay
I'd be happy to actually can Ethan
frisbee Boomerang yes or no how about
just frisbee Boomer
yes the alpha music all right I'm asking
the community dads rise up you all know
that one's real
dads rise up
hit that yes button for dads everywhere
wait this is kind of confusing Paul can
Ethan frisbee Boomerang yes what's
confusing about it
Maybe I'm Wrong I I thought I should say
should Ethan Boomerang a frisbee
should no that's way more confusing can
I Boomerang of frisbee
rather than all right well despite 43
haters out in the audience I'll take the
58 uh dub good Wing yeah
I'm gonna make a video remind me when I
get home
I'm gonna do that and I'm gonna bring in
the receipts and then you will all
bow before me
as the ultimate dad
thank you all right we are exactly of 30
minutes
um so maybe we should do all right so
let's thank our sponsor
and then actually I have another thing
well I got to ask you what is this Sam
I'll show it real fast and we'll get
into it
um
what yeah it's Sam on tick tock
just saying this
Kim Kardashian
Kim Kardashian what is happening Kim
Kardashian
this is my favorite thing
so I have questions about that you do
what y'all present I have answers after
uh this one sponsor who I'm gonna thank
uh Express VPN
[Applause]
called mine without expressvpn is like
changing while leaving your window wide
open
yeah
you might not have anything to hide but
why give random creeps a chance to
invade your privacy that's fair close
close the curves you know if you're
gonna be dick out
you know why does everyone need a VPN
when you go online without one internet
service providers can see every single
website you visit and I know you sick
[__] out there got a lot to hide
they can legally sell this information
without your consent to add companies
and Tech Giants and then they use this
data to Target you
that's actually kind of gnarly
real if they have like a full profile
about like everything you do on the
internet everything you've done that's
so invasive the ISP collects and sells
your data do they really do that
yep
yo that's [__] up
and so here well there's a good reason
to use expressvpn here's another one
browse more anonymously when you use
expressvpn isps can't see what you're
doing online your identity is anonymized
and uh by their VPN secure server and
also your data is maximum protected
so easy to use fired up on an app click
one button Bob's your uncle you're on
you're surfing works on all devices
phones laptops and even routers so
everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can be
protected
I love uh I love it because vpns are
really useful for a whole different slew
of reasons
um but one of them is connecting you
know if you if you connect to like any
streaming service from another country
via VPN get a whole new catalog of
content a lot of stuff is Geo blocked
if you go to like Japan Netflix via a
VPN so it thinks you're in Japan
good
so much great content you're gonna find
there
yeah Studio ghibli's on there
probably all kinds of badass animes on
there
uh also I used to use
I used to use a vpns when I was a kid
too
do prank calls is that a thing
probably not something to recommend
doing
is that something you need a PPN to do
I I suppose you could
[Music]
you know
randomizes your data
anyway
secure your online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com H3 today right now that's
exp r e s s vpn.com H3 and you get an
extra three months for free
yes I said that correctly three months
for free
at expressvpn.com H3 right now thank you
thank you to our wonderful sponsor
expressvpn
[Music]
right here
sick all right so Sam I'll play one more
time and then
I'll let you uh take it from there game
got action
Kim Kardashian
[Laughter]
your thoughts
so this is me practicing my Michaela how
does you say her last name nogira
she's a makeup uh tick tocker and she
posted this tick tock maybe last week
where everyone accuses her of faking her
super thick Boston accent what can I is
this the same girl that was in
controversy over the fake lashes yes oh
she sounds like Carrie Fisher she's
getting Heat
yes and so
she was talking about Kim Kardashian's
Met Gala look and her accent was just it
was like Kim Kardashian had this oh God
that's the that's the original one and
so she's saying this is real
had this absolutely yeah that's a fake
I honestly it sounds a lot like her it
sounds I've been practicing Ian can
confirm I say this constantly
I thought you were being uh over the top
that's literally how she sounds
Kardashians Kim Kardashian Kim
Kardashian
can we see it in person Sam get him
Kardashians Kim Kardashian had this apps
you got to get this one okay you gotta
get this one too Zach Kim Kardashian
absolutely stunning sexy look at the Met
Gala and you can recreate it at home but
why do people care if she's fake in her
accent and she's just being a character
right
or did she say she's specifically like
this is who I am oh she
um
says that it's real
why would she lie about that she said
that because there are old like videos
of her from when she was a tour guide
and at school and she says that when she
was filming those because she doesn't
have the accent in it she was getting
rid of it because she was going to be a
news broadcaster so she learned how to
not do her accent nobody sounds like
that's her story somebody I went to
college with uh grew up with her and
said it's a fake really yeah whoa
literally no nobody sounds oh AV I love
what you're seeing back to BTS
did you get it down uh I didn't I was
afraid that thing might kill me if it
falls on my head AV attempted to put the
prolapse on a spike
a pike
to get the pizza down but it wasn't
successful but nobody sounds like this
right I'm gonna be using this brush for
the majority of this look now with this
look I'm only gonna do now with this
Foundation people started using that
sound but Kim Kardashian showing their
like pets and babies and it's always
like a jump scare their baby like looks
like a camera like what the [__]
that is funny I like that you give it a
shot Ethan let me let's hear you I I
tried I I can't get it Kardashians
Kim Kardashian
Kim
Kardashian Kim Kardashian Kim Kardashian
Sam's is really good
sounds like she's throat singing uh
Mongolian throat singing
okay what it sounds like yeah
Kim Kardashian
here is I guess people doing the sound
yeah that's [__] good okay
oh that's funny
you had absolutely these poor pets let's
see this little girl
I guess I gotta do one with shredder I
didn't know that this was all happening
out there
oh that's good Kim Kardashian I get it
now
let's watch one more time with all that
in context Kim Kardashian
Kim Kardashian
it's good
you you got it
that one was extra good now was this
post uh fika Fish Construction so did
all the fumes get here had a little bit
I did this like I don't know like last
week oh okay and I just sent it to my
friend and I was like I'm gonna post
this this is so funny
okay
[Music]
let's all do it at the same time ready
Kim Kardashian and I'll play it ready
that's like a fever dream that's awesome
all right well shout out to uh Michaela
shut up who's giving who's giving like
Mo from Simpsons yeah yeah I love her
tutorials actually Kim Kardashian had
this absolutely yes girl we love your
tutorials what about the one about her
eyelashes did you follow that one I wear
that mascara because of that video oh I
was like oh I wonder if it's like
actually good and it was sold out I
couldn't even find it oh my God and yeah
so ultimately I think it was probably a
good move for uh L'Oreal but I love that
so does it make your eyes as as
voluminous as she claims I think so I
think it works really well and so do you
think maybe she wasn't faking it oh I
don't know I think that there was maybe
some foul play yeah but I do think that
it's a great product there it is
there it is Kim Kardashian
[Applause]
that's very funny okay good excellent
well
um hunger ff's calling at uh two friends
of the show great guy all around great
guy
top prolapser in the world by far and
he's calling in today to talk about his
new achievement and uh
uh
prolapse technology
wish I could show it to you guys it's
just not worth it but
we posted it on the Twitter right yeah
it's on Twitter if you go back to I
guess Monday yeah
but I'll tell you this
who wants to try to put that up their
butt for the show
I said I'll see how the the prostate
exam goes and we'll go for that on field
reporting I mean that thing starts it's
like has a square top and it starts like
this thick boy you raising your hand
volunteer no no I just I just heard the
pizza fall or the dough oh the dough
fell
is anyone thinking about pizza since we
threw that dough
just me I thought Pizza gives you
diarrhea now uh yeah what's that have to
do with eating it same man looking out
for you
that's later dude yeah that's a problem
for future man
so uh about our big teddy fresh drop
tomorrow about the classic so I am
wearing this shirt pocket tea fresh
teddy bear logo so nice oh my God is
that who's wearing one today that crew
now looks so nice
Yeah clean as a whistle boy what is
clean as a whistle man like what's clean
about whistles
the sound they make explain it no you
gotta keep a whistle clean because it
will um it won't get dirt and dust in
there it won't blow properly
huh
I don't know just clean as a whistle
made all that up I don't know yeah but
uh I got the prices here for you guys
this is coming out tomorrow at 10 A.M
and again this is an historic drop
the prices this t-shirt is 20 bucks
I mean where can you even get like a
nice designer shirt for 20 bucks with a
pocket that's hot nowhere
the sweatshirt that uh Olivia and AV are
wearing is 55 dollars
again
we somehow got we dropped it like 20
bucks on that one
uh hats and beanies 20 bucks
hoodie 60
I don't know how much the hoodie bear
ears one is but it's around the same
price
that's the most expensive item in the
collection is 60 for the hoodie I think
that's the zip up hoodie too it's more
expensive because the zipper you know
and we did nice zippers we did the
nicest zippers they're not that cheap
[__] it's that YKK zipper if you guys
know what I'm talking about
that's that good [__] if you buy clothes
and it doesn't have YKK they are going
cheap on you
that's a fact
ain't nothing like those YKK zippers
the only time you'll find a better
zipper than YKK is if you buy like a
Gucci and they have like their own
House made you know stainless steel uh
branded zipper
the house yeah but we did that YKK you
don't go cheap on the zipper
so uh tomorrow at 10 A.M I'm very
excited about it and I hope you guys
enjoy
I think I'm gonna be rocking these for a
long time
you know
it's perfect
so uh budge you're a little hunger
the one and only YKK are cheap why are
you saying that you don't know anything
about your well you don't know anything
dude Gary on Miller
how dare you say that
zippers zippers were invented in Sweden
is that right yep yep that's right oh
and I agree with you that what you're
saying is true I know about the YKK yeah
but you know about YKK yeah yeah yeah
because we invented it is that a Swedish
Thing no I'm kidding I'm making a joke
but you're right
thank you thank you so much so okay
let's talk to our boy a hunger let's
check it Zipper was invented by an
American inventor in Chicago
[__] life hold on
is it maybe that he is of Swedish
descent that's still America we get that
one
um that is Danish propaganda propaganda
those [__]
wait hold on hold on where did you learn
that is do they teach kids that in
school
uh yeah and the zipper everybody knows
the zoo the swedes invented the zipper
we love the zipper here in Sweden
everyone in here Google it Google I
didn't know we're Americans yeah
okay here I've got it I've got it who
invented the zipper he was Swedish
American there you go called Gideon send
back
information here
who's generally credited with inventing
the modern zipper as we know it he first
registered his patent for the device in
Germany but it wasn't until 1917 that it
received a patent for a device called a
separable fastener
yo this man patented the zipper what a
[__] King
yeah
Big W so are you getting a different
name because I'm seeing Gideon sun to
back
I'm getting uh I'm on the Wikipedia page
for zipper for zippers and right at the
very beginning in 1892 Whitcomb L Judson
an American girl from Chicago patent
Patton
patented we have the original design
from which the modern device evolved
this we have two very different uh now
we're getting such different answers I'm
getting my information from sweden.se so
that that can't be that's not all vital
that's not biased at all sweden.gov
yeah
oh I see wait hold on let me look up the
guy here's the guy this is American
propaganda maybe okay well I just
Googled it hold on here's the guy Gideon
sundebuck
he was born in
uh he was born in Sweden yeah he died in
America
thank you so who gets him
well I mean wait it mentions Hudson hold
on he built upon the previous work of
other Engineers such as talk with how
Max
Judson
wait where did you read that hunger FF
is on the line hold on hold on love down
in the choir section second paragraph
Okay
in 1905 Gideon sundeback started at to
work and the Westinghouse electric and
Manufacturing Company in Pittsburgh so
this all happened in America
this is American Ingenuity baby [__]
yeah you think
you think a zipper could have been
invented in Sweden yeah I mean
245 years of slinging dick baby
America there's a reason you're moving
here come on Love American Supremacy
baby I'll come to America and other than
something from the zipper all the way to
the atomic bomb baby
it's all America
1906 sunbeck was hired to work for the
universal Fastener company of Hoboken
New Jersey subsequently in 1909 sunback
was promoted to the position okay wait
sunback made several advances in the
development of the zipper between 1906.
I'm sure he he probably he probably
improved it and made it much better but
he didn't invent it right and how could
a Swede
but to be honest I would have to see
what the original one looked like
because here it says known for invention
of the zipper
right so we're getting named what was
judson's name with Whitcomb L Judson
what a name what come L Judson here's
this idiot
yeah and then he also known for
invention of the zipper that's what I'm
saying so I guess this was a
collaborative effort so here's uh here
this was the this was the Manhattan
Project of 1909 right yeah
here look oh that's a mess bro what is
that what the heck is that dude it's an
early zipper no I think the sweet guy
see the design no look it does the exact
same thing there's a metal piece here
and it pulls it together and it and it
combines it it's a zipper it is really
an invention that we take for granted
yeah zippers are awesome yeah
we can share in the glory I don't want
to make this a national well hold on so
this is the original one now let me see
the new guys the Swedish guys uh what
was his name right
uh
uh [__] let me go back
Gideon Gideon Sunday
here oh here it is I got a picture here
so this guy took it to the next level
here's his [__]
it's like a modern zipper it does what
do you mean yeah are we crazy oh I guess
we're seeing the back of it aren't we
I'm just because it doesn't have the
little tab our boy Gideon he took it all
the way to the zoo so he improved it I
think that's fair it's a collaborative
effort you know humanity is always
Advanced when we look Beyond borders and
lines in the sand and we come together
as people you know what I'll take that
handshake well it's it's as it says Sir
Isaac Newton said uh I only see so far
because I stand on the back of giants of
the Giants before me yeah that's that's
true and uh of course Gideon was talking
about the great
uh
the very great
uh whatever his name is the other guy
yeah
all right let's talk speaking of zippers
let's talk to hunger
let's zip something open
let me see that ass me brother
all right you guys remember running them
into the zoom one second Hunger FF is
here uh if you guys remember him he
called in first time when Howie Mandel
was on the show and he did a live
prolapse demonstration for Howie
fantastic moment
I'm sorry I don't mean to always be
testing the no I'm kidding it's not your
fault you're all good so how have you
been
I've been really really great how about
you guys how has business been been good
since our last appearance on the show
it's been really insanely
um overwhelmingly awesome like the
amount of threads and stuff about me
since I was on this doors
um it's a little crazy well a positive I
hope oh yeah you guys it was you know
what's funny is I had a friend of mine
that was like warned he's like there's
you know it can they can it can be a
little crazy on that show sometimes and
I'm like okay like I braced myself for
like negative kind of like back you know
feedback but it was it's been nothing
but positives I think thank you I think
we can be crazy but we try to be crazy
nice for the most part right Crazy
Nights yeah so um obviously would you
say that some of our fans are got
converted into the prolapse life do you
think there's some people from our
audience that are now consuming your
content
I mean there's definitely a new group of
people that are following me on Twitter
that I met you know new people that
definitely came from from your somewhere
okay cool wow Super Troopers out there
it's awesome it's awesome what I would
say everything
sorry go ahead hunger your fan base is
rabid yeah they're they are and they're
they're the best they really are amazing
but I think everyone was taken by just
how sweet and gentle and authentic you
were so I think it was uh due to your
your genuineness so we're here today to
announce this really remarkable
um achievement
this has got to be the first ever
prolapse dildo is that right
it's it's definitely the first prolapse
dildo I've ever seen
um it's totally one of a kind and
different uh than anything else on the
market right now and so I'm hoping that
it makes it made a big enough Splash and
it's crashed my website today oh my God
do you know how many so are you selling
a lot of them right now or do you have a
finite is it sold out
I promised myself I wasn't gonna take a
look at the sales until the end of the
day but the fact that this is bigger
than like the first day I launched the
website is I I didn't crash the site on
the first day and it's crashed the site
now so it's pretty wild wow
so I gotta I gotta ask you about the
logistics of this thing when I first saw
it I thought it would be like a
fleshlight
you put your dick and the prolapse but
what I found is that it's just a giant
[__] dildo
and the original plan was for it to be a
Fleshlight and
um and a dildo at the same time I kind
of wanted something like go [__] it and
whatever but
um that is going to end up being like a
version 2.0 at some point down the line
okay yeah yeah because I find I don't
know that there's an a lot of uh people
who can make use of such a great sized
uh dildo
well we're doing it in four sizes so
there's it's been scaled down like
um there's a small medium large and an
extra large so there's uh the XL is the
closest to my actual right for the
authentic and so it was the idea because
the tip of it is is quite thick like
there's no easing in of this toy so is
the intended use of this thing just to
lube up and go in like it you just it's
just it is what it is how do you
recommend people to use it you know so
hanky's towards the company that I
partnered with to do the toy uh they are
kind of known for more
um extreme or like kind of like out
there toys they do like realistic sci-fi
all kinds of things from all different
skill levels and so we did skill level
meaning
um how much you can fit in your book
right right pro pro level being the you
can fit the most
yeah it's pretty wild like the the toys
that they make are you know pretty crazy
but um the idea is basically just to
kind of create something that I get
asked so frequently by guys that I film
with or play with
like can you [__] me with it and I'm
like no it's like [__] logistically
impossible so they so I figured you know
if we did something together that I
would want to kind of cater to that type
of kind of ah yeah so there was a need
a lot of your co-star says I want you to
put your prolapse in me but it's too
soft you can't do it right
it's just like I mean imagine trying to
kind of like fit two people together
that way it's like it's kind of
logistically impossible right so um yeah
it's uh I've tried it you know we've
tried it but I mean it's it's a little
bit kind of difficult so
so there's probably a lot of high skill
level people out there probably looking
forward to inserting that in their uh
buttholes eh
well when I got it I got the box of them
the ones that I got I received to sell
myself and I'm like oh look it's a box
of buttholes like it's like it's like it
just it gets crazy so um there's a lot
of people out there I think that um you
know at least Niche people that are
going to be really excited and eager to
to play with it this is exciting I got
to tell you that thing's well made man
that is like if you talk about ask me
boy that's like 10 pounds to ask me
and it is thick I was slapping it and it
was like boom
I watched um did you see the uh did you
notice the hair around the base yeah of
course how could I have missed that
it's sort of insane so yeah I don't know
if um it's wild it did an amazing job
with it so so I know traditionally
um
when you make a sex toy like that a man
or let's just talk dildo because that's
the most uh mainstream we'll put his
dick
in a kind of type of molding situation
silicon molding situation
and then they fill it with silicon and
they get a perfect mold of of the deck
now now the prolapse the technique of
doing that it's got to be a little bit
different were you able to dip your
prolapse into a mold how did that work
um so there was I I would like to leave
a little bit of it to the imagination as
for how we got it to be as accurate as
it was but um we definitely I'll just
say that there was somebody out there
that's very familiar with every detail
of insides more familiar than I am now
at this point so um we didn't
necessarily do a um a real traditional
mold or casting but it's um it's a it's
a similar price I don't want to get too
specific as how we did it but it's it's
it's it's as accurate of a replica that
I can go that we that we could have
possibly made
realistically stick like like me like
doing that into like a like a like a
mold would have been you know it was a
lot of Hoops to jump through to make it
happen
so and so um well what are you are you
guys protecting some proprietary secret
here what's going on what's the mystery
I just kind of want to we're going to
want to leave it a little bit to the
imagination as to how we made it happen
like the um the actual process of um
I'll say it was it was sculpted okay so
did you did you prolapse uh in front of
an artist or somehow somehow like that
kind of like yeah something like that
some people along those lines yeah it
was like um it was basically kind of
like we had a we had a um yeah there was
an artist that was kind of involved that
kind of sculpted it based on
you know so can you do
can you dangle the prolapse out for that
long
oh yeah oh my goodness whoa okay wow so
you kind of were just Pro whole meat out
for a for a fair bit of time what's the
longest you've had your meat out at one
time before
does it dry out
so as I always always say that it's like
as long as it stays um wet and warm the
sun's kind of gross but I mean like it's
uh then it's fine yeah it can be out for
as long as it wants or as long as I want
but um so it's like a it's like a whale
in a sense you've got to just keep it
you keep putting water on it and keep
you know keep it comfortable and happy
yeah
it's my ass whale oh my gosh yeah
yeah we're gonna change the name from
ask me to ask whale ask Orca so what's
the technique of keeping the your ass
orc uh uh happy and uh you know out
um like I mean just you know I always
saw people I have guys that will come
over and do straight up sessions with me
where they just want to play with that
and so I'm like uh as long as there's
enough Lube on it and it stays we turn
the AC down like they're off okay um
then it's usually okay so just lots of
lube and like maybe the playing and the
friction probably helps keep it warm as
well
yeah I guess yeah yeah it's sort of
weird when I talk about it like this
because in the context of like play it's
all really hot and fun and like crazy
but then when you sit back in a non-play
situation and start talking about it
it's like it's very kind of like
what is it's a it's such a wild kind of
crazy well I think it's important that
we stop and pause and analyze you know
what we're doing in life I don't find it
gross I find it fascinating I mean you
are one of your your uh rare kind of
specialized person in this world and uh
we all applaud your ass orca
yeah dude love that like a beached whale
can you guys check his website I can't
say the URL I'm sorry but check I want
to see if it's sold out
well it's down it might I think my web
guy's working on it as oh it's still
down
we're still working on getting it up but
it's um it crashed like maybe like a
half hour ago the amount of traffic that
was in the site is is ridiculous right
now so man
can I ask you what's the what's the MSRP
on those things because it looks real
expensive
they range it ranges from about 150 to
like 250 um depending on the size that
you get yeah I'm not surprised that is a
thick piece of [__] meat dude you
know
yeah it's it's our Platinum turned
silicone so it's like the highest kind
of quality toy that you can actually
right make and so if
um it's not like and a lot of the old
school toys they would make with
materials that would break down over
time this is going to last forever
basically yeah we tried to visit it we
we got a we got a timeout
the people are hungry and all they want
is ass meat it's crazy
you know it would be interesting
oh what's that
to get [__] by your own prolapse could
possibly be an interesting concept for
you yeah that's that's uh go [__]
yourself to a new meaning or to a new
level but we're definitely gonna I'm
gonna be doing something like that at
some point in the future uh I was
thinking about doing like a reverse like
base first oh my God hunger
you know what you know what that is pro
level my friend that is that because the
base is just a [__] he's the best of
what he does yeah you're the best you're
a pro you're Pro so you so that's have
you have you [__] your own prolapse
yet or is that uh to be to be uh
continued I just got them um like the I
just got them like yesterday
um so I haven't had a chance to to try
it out myself yeah okay that's exciting
does it turn I mean there's not really
many people out there that can I mean I
think I'm the only person that can say
they got [__] by their own [__]
then absolutely I mean
that's a huge come on one of a kind
that's what I'm saying and
um
would you could you get turned on by
your own ass me in a sense if you
because I know you're you're a
connoisseur of this style that you
participate in and I'm trying to think
like
could you get turned on by your own ask
me or is it uh not doesn't work when
it's yourself you know
um I'll tell you it's very difficult for
me to find like porn to get off to you
because I'll like look for that type of
porn and it's just me
um
looking like you know whatever site and
I'm just like okay this is the three
pages of me are there's something else
yeah there's there's you know this it's
definitely kind of something that's
growing in popularity that I've been
able to find some other guys that are
doing similar stuff but I'm not saying I
was turned on by my own that's kind of
like I'm I don't think that's really
necessarily accurate but
um I do make the kind of porn that turns
me on so
um you know what I mean it's like it's
like it's the kind of porn that I would
want to watch so uh I guess in that
sense it is stuff that turns me on yeah
you well I guess if there's just not
enough out there you probably just end
up consuming your own content you know
I guess maybe yeah it's uh it's
literally It's tricky to find stuff that
gets you know because and then the other
thing is I know most of these guys right
these are your friends I know it's it's
kind of weird to beat off to my friends
so brothers and prolapse
basically yeah how many of you what if
you go to like one of these popular
corn websites how many views is do your
kind of videos get like on the Mac side
uh
I think my one most popular on uh
PornHub has like five or six million yo
let's go what's the percentage of what's
the like ratio do you know
um it's pretty divided because it's
divisive right yeah yeah yeah if I I was
gonna do like us like a hunger FF reads
mean comments kind of video one oh
that's funny so because you know I think
the comments are like they range from
like oh my God this is the greatest
thing ever to oh my God I need to like
bleach my eyeballs right so it's in your
uh the comments on the the video you
guys posted were pretty awesome too
uh which one I don't remember
Twitter
oh yeah
hold on my page and then they went to
the uh the pin video and they went a
little crazy oh right right we did show
a lot Amy do you have any questions for
Hunger
no
I've rendered him speechless yeah now I
just land to like ratio I'm seeing 90 to
100 a lot of people they dig it okay
that's so nice that's so very nice
yeah
people are saying they can't rewind I
don't know what that is Dan I
I know what it is
we don't want people to be able to
rewind oh you can turn that off yeah
yeah baby
oh oh
so um well I got a question for you
because you're at the top of the game
you kind of own this whole
genre how are you doing financially are
you set for life at this point
um I'm trying to uh I'm always kind of
like on a grind like I'm always trying
to like see you know it's like I'm
trying to think of like most people take
this type of thing like a career into it
it's like something that has like a
shelf life but I've been doing this now
for like 16 years wow
it's all I've known for most of my you
know my entire adult life so
um I'm setting you know I've got
retirement and stocks and stuff like
that that I'm investing so I know this
could all end tomorrow you know what I
mean like it could so I'm trying to keep
it so that
of setting myself up for the future but
eventually the plan is to go behind the
camera and not be so involved anymore in
events and stuff like that but this was
the next phase coming for me how many
how many good years do you think you
have left
I mean in terms of prolapsing you know
in front of the camera
I mean like as long as people aren't
sick of me I'm gonna keep doing it but
there it is yeah yeah I mean as long as
you know people are still kind of
watching I mean I I love doing this
stuff it's the creative aspect of it is
really great for me like being able to
edit and stuff like that that's like my
creative outlet and um it's fun for me
that person I'm getting reports that
your highest viewed video is 9.4 million
on p hub oh my god oh combined combined
okay combine that's a lot model rank 78
you're actually on the leaderboard
that's crazy
well before like do you remember did you
know about the PornHub kind of like
cleanse when they had like yeah yeah so
I was um before then I had like a uh I
was updating PornHub really regularly
with like like longer videos and um then
after the purge I was sort of kind of
just do trailers and stuff now so before
that it was it was a little bit higher
but wait why did you stop posting
because I thought the purge was just
that they removed unverified videos
they removed unverified videos but then
also they sorry I gotta fix the camera
uh They removed on very quick videos but
then the
um uh stopped allowing you to post
videos for paid uh paid content oh
yeah so they like they took away their
model program so when the model program
left I I left with it because I was like
oh so wait they used to pay people to
post and then they stopped
yeah so the same week that I got kicked
off yeah
they used to used to be able to sell
videos on PornHub and they we can't do
it anymore it's it's pretty it's wild do
you know why they stopped doing that
it was the um the revenge porn lawsuit
uh those the girls the women that kind
of came together and said that they were
being like you know that PornHub wasn't
removing their content and then visa and
MasterCard pulled their contract oh
and so they couldn't they can't process
payments anymore so without being able
to process payments the models can't
sell videos
that's such a shame because I mean if
you're verifying your ID it's a shame
that all these other models are
suffering
I was one of the only people that
survived the purge but at that point it
was like they can't buy my videos so why
I'm
did you have a huge drop in Revenue when
that happened
the same week I got kicked off of only
fans was the same day that PornHub got
um
I crawled into a ball and cried and then
I decided to just start my own website
so oh my goodness why why would wait
only fans doesn't allow you either
only fans won't allow me either they're
you know it's interesting about only
fans is that they're Incorporated in the
United Kingdom
uh which has some of the most strictest
obscenity laws on the planet
um
so anything Kink fetish
um anything outside of like kind of
traditional vanilla sex is not allowed
on only fans that's so silly they're
like only sex that we think is cool
yeah it's really cool
[__] the King King Charles could never
yeah it was it was a pretty pretty rough
week when that happened but um I turned
it into something positive it's like I
decided I was like okay I'm gonna take
what I've saved and build my own
proprietary site and go from there and
see what happens and I roll the dice and
here I am on your show good for you good
for you
um well hunger we're all so happy for
your success you know thanks for calling
in it's always a joy and I mean you
prolapsing for Howie Mandel for us is
definitely a highlight for me
you know I can't get over the look on
your face when I did it with him because
it look you looked like a kid in a candy
store
that is amazing that was like a full
Crescendo of planning and and uh
maestroing to get Howie in the office
and then you drop in trial I mean it was
just a it was a magical moment for me so
thank you for giving me that
all right absolutely stay lubed out
there okay just keep it Lube keep it
warm
thanks guys and it was um yeah it was
great to be back yeah keep it wet keep
it lubed keep it warm
all right
hunger when you when you are
masturbating do you put stuff in your
butt or are you cool just to hit the the
dick
I mean like I
is just by yourself I'm just curious if
you if you need to go that route or if
you you know what I mean
I don't get off usually with any without
anything on my ass okay I see that's the
whole thing the brain is rewired to kind
of take it back
and so when you're getting off by
yourself what kind of stuff do you find
yourself putting up there
honestly generally like my entire toy
collection is is all the company that I
ended up working with so um I've been
you know a huge fan of them forever and
so I've had pretty much all the stuff
that they've they've made so do you
think it's gonna sound great go ahead
and I'll go ahead go ahead no you go
ahead let's just say um uh I also have
like a custom this is uh you know like
guys that use dick pumps
yeah I've got a pumpkin
oh a prolapse
okay that's fun it's pretty wild so um
the idea of the prolapse uh pump is to
make it more swollen more more large
pretty much yeah that's it it's pretty
extreme and like you know it's it's it
is you know but my entire sex life is a
little extreme
and so when you were so we're talking
they make these so what kind of dildo
are we using is it like just a giant
penis or is it like a monster tentacle
uh it's just I mean like it's they're
just giant dicks so but it's funny guys
a lot of guys come over to play whatever
you know film and they're like do you
have toys you have toys I'm like I have
choice for me so like right I bring them
out
um right right right show me how thick
we're talking I'm just curious is that
like a real dick or like a
uh just show me in thickness with your
hands
holy [__] brother
so it's not like our life's it's not a
life-size dick it's like a
yeah nobody has a dick that big we're
titled I mean like the Goliath or the
ogre or something like that right right
the Orca
yeah the orchard you're the man dude I
love that
you're the man
thanks hunger you take care okay we're
rooting for you we love you
guys too helpful you're a sweet man
God bless you keep it up
easy have a good one thanks for letting
me come on bye hunger
good man all right later guys a good man
you gotta respect someone who's just
who thought you could apologetically
himself that's it no good at his craft
yep he's pro-love such a nice guy he
knows what he's here on this Earth he's
Master Level Pro doesn't describe yeah
this man doesn't get off unless it's
this thick man is a pro with the letter
the Goliath bro Michael Jordan a
prolapse is right there yeah the goat
I think he's such a sweet guy though in
all honesty and we love that firm you
know
um
not every day you meet a legend you know
there's a few times in my life where I
feel like I was looking at a legend
first time was when I saw Celine Dion
live and this may be the second Celine
Dion and hunger they both have a lot of
in common in terms of talent they do
yeah Abu seemed to be I looked over at
you uh
running around and I just I noticed that
it was
yeah
sorry we're just uh so anyway but thank
you to hunger I mean he's the man
the Goliath bra
oh Jesus Christ
yep yep God damn it
hold the [__] phone
yeah
uh
came Kardashian Kim Kardashian Kim got
it you've got it yeah
Kim Kardashian
all right I'm gonna let the kids out
what does that mean you're opening chat
back up
game Kardashian playground
um hold on hold on can you can you can
you just mute the mics play give him a
error message I need to ask him I'm
gonna hold the button
hold the button yeah you're just gonna
race this whole part no all this here
let's wait a second
so that people understand here I'm
waiting 20 seconds right now so you all
understand why it's about to cut away
wait you like when can I talk not yet
not yet
feel free to submit new stuff on the
subredditer for the cards
we updated every week go ahead so they
can't see this no so so you cropped it
out and Yeah and how long was it on the
screen like it's like a minute probably
and how did you crop it out and then He
adjusted this camera at one point yeah
what the [__] hunger is a monster
dad told me dude if he comes if he comes
on again we gotta screen his frame
that's [__] up hunger's killing me
dude all right are you ready to come
back well I don't know what to do about
that that's pretty bad
we can blur I can I can set the episode
to Auto unless when we as soon as we go
off the air and then we'll crop it out
and just post it later once it's cut out
I mean what else can we do but see that
doesn't really eliminate our liability
I mean
what else can we do
it is
it's smaller than what you think it's
not that big let's just let's just when
the episode's done crop it out
the whole dildo part and the [__] part
and just hope for the best
okay because I don't think on listing is
going to matter if people report it and
YouTube sees it
so what's the order of operations here I
think just when we're done just crop it
out and up [__] pray
okay
delete the whole episode for that no
just his inner just his interview
what we can settle at after we go up
there but we we gotta act like we didn't
talk about anything when you impress the
button no but we should decide because
it is pretty important
I
think you should just cut the interview
and then re-upload it as a highlight
when it's censored cut the whole
interview out yeah and then upload it as
a highlight well no you can cut just cut
the dick in the dildo part yeah but it's
like the whole beginning of the
interview but you can blur stuff too
when you cut there's like a blur option
you could blur it oh I wonder if the
blur's faster what
no if it's well if it's cut well it
doesn't matter either way yeah it
doesn't matter either way it doesn't the
damage is done yeah the damage from
YouTube's perspective then the best
thing we can do is just hope nobody
reports it and cut out
so let's just cut let's just now let's
just cut the dildo in the picture you
want to cut the whole thing well again
that's the whole beginning of the
interview well who cares it'll just be a
little weird
just be a little awkward
okay man we could cut the whole thing
you think just cut the whole thing I
feel bad cutting it he did [__] us
though he knew what he was doing dude no
he knew what he was doing
you
you think he did that intentionally I
don't know yeah I think so Zach told him
directly so yeah why would he do that I
think so too
he had on he had explicit instructions
of what to do and he didn't do it so I I
don't know what to say
either he's
a lot yeah I mean okay let's do the show
let's do the show let's just cut out the
absent obscene part I'm in favor of
keeping the interview if it if it's
awkward it's fine okay it just look a
little glitchy all right let's come back
all right releasing right now hey guys
we just had a little bit of a technical
issue thank you everybody for uh
standing by and standing back
hope you enjoyed those button screens if
you'd like to see yeah you got to see
the whole Loop this time did they see
the whole loop I don't think it was no I
don't I think it's like a 15 minute
video or something but it's pretty long
at this point I'm always at a new one so
if you'd like to submit your own feel
free to on our subreddit we have our own
button flare have a chance to have your
work scene on the show
all right let's see here we well we got
all kinds of fun stuff uh always nice to
hear from Hunger though
do you think
I was wondering that you think he swore
seven digits
you could probably really don't know I
don't know I mean I guess there is a lot
of money in like the very like the
hyper-specific like Kink stuff he's like
yeah based on ability absolutely 100 I
think he deserves it right he's the goat
um
well good for him man he could probably
fit a million ones in his butthole
yeah just saying
all right let's see we got some other
fun stuff like the quartering is going
to be in a boxing match this year let's
go okay keemstar he's out keemstar is
going to work with like the dumbest
weirdest stupidest oh my God like throw
away I mean he brought us Boogie verse
swings though and uh Zach loved that
right
no
you're not gonna say a word man what
what happened you didn't get toasted for
that I found it entertaining quality
boxing match you weren't the only one we
watched it on the show yeah quality now
review Tech USA versus quartering now
this is this is gonna be the match up
the
that everybody's waiting for here boy
hell yeah
super exciting times
yep
yeah next year they're gonna have to
Brian toys reviews the uh
the guy who dissects gummy bears oh yeah
Ryan toys reviews is growing up I'll
tell you man don't underestimate him
he's getting bigger
very exciting has um quartering
commented on this yet
all right let me see
I'm stoked I think quartering's gonna
take the Dub here look I'm 40. I'm tired
I'm sweaty I'm fat I'm overweight no
[__] way bro no no no no no no no
keemstar says would I get canceled if I
put EDP four four five in a boxing match
against donut operator yes do not you
[__] psycho
Jesus
edp-445 of course is the guy who cupcake
this one cupcake guy I mean absolutely
annihilated for going to meet I don't
remember how old she was like 14 or
something it's like 13 14 yeah 13 my God
what a nightmare that would be
[__]
yeah please don't do that but like you
give a [__]
yeah I can't wait to give this pedophile
a big payday
it says keemstar
I can't wait to make a bunch of money
off this pedophile
so uh congratulations uh to quartering
very much looking forward to that one
there
uh Crowder
has a new meltdown on Twitter
this guy I can't believe he's talking
about anything bro after what happened
like bro dude that doesn't work for me
either
Steven to YouTube that doesn't work
this [__] idiot loser who by the way
already left YouTube is crying
he hasn't left
so uh he had Alex Jones host the show it
looks like or wait a bunch of them
inside footage Alex Jones Alex Jones
house
well if you're having Alex Jones host
your show who's been banned it stands to
assume that it's probably going to get
removed and I don't even know what was
in the content I'm sure it was some
psychotic
transphobic homophobic fall experience
Theory yeah yeah I actually have the
clip of it I was saving it for leftovers
but since we're talking about this I
might as well show you
yeah I guess um we we got taken off the
air once for showing Alex Jones content
if you recall but they reversed it yeah
but remember it was the only time that's
ever happened they actually cut our live
stream
it wasn't just that that's right we've
straight up got bumped and then Joe
Rogan dm'd me you remember that
that did prompt that didn't it Bill
Rogan's like what happened dude
this is ridiculous he got all up in arms
about it sucking a ding dong I was like
um but yeah I don't know if we could
show it because it was uh what does he
saying it he is pretending to be Asian
and pulling his uh eyes back and doing
my man I was right it was super racist
it was unbelievably racist
while they were in the middle of a
discussion about like
um Asians being targeted for uh hate
crimes by the way all of a sudden he
just decided just kind of out of the
blue he's like I identify as an Asian
and then started doing a really horrible
stereotypical Chinese uh just probably I
guess better not to watch it yeah I feel
like yeah I don't know
as much as I would like to watch it
oh yeah screencap's a good idea yeah we
could do that right ditch I mean we're
just talking about the news here [__]
ditch as the host guest host of louder
with Crowder Alex Jones has reported
saying he identifies as Asian
here is oh my God
dude what is wrong with you bro you
somehow
again you just look like a demon brother
while talking about uh anti-asian
discrimination
decided to uh I guess then launch into
this bit I get I guess in the
conservative spheres this one still
kills that's crazy straight from the
playground kills it kills Crowder's
YouTube channel hopefully
yeah so deterring just like the image of
him
I just can't look anymore oh they're
trying to roast him because he went this
dude's surfs TV went on Temple destroyed
them and he said hooking up with a trans
woman isn't gay she's a woman
and so now they're trying to sucking
dick ain't gay well brother I got bad
news for you all your homies are gay
hmm
there it is there it is so he said [__]
you YouTube I don't get I don't give a
[__] that we're one strike away from
being banned permanently from the
platform
we will not pacify we will not kowtow
and we will not stop
except for the two weeks where we're not
allowed to post
either not now not ever
we say when it's over hashtag mug Club
says when it's over
not some Patsy in Silicon Valley
and then meanwhile at home how what's he
sound like
not that tough someday
don't miss tomorrow's episode This Means
War the stakes have never been higher
who's [__] reading this [__] and
getting this all the time
here's another tweet from just a few
months ago
tomorrow is war last time that he went
to war with YouTube sleep well he just
wanted to do more sketches
I think that's it dressed up is like uh
a warrior or something more cosplays
I can't wait is also declaring war
another time last year he also said he
was suing them which was a lie right
this lawsuit did he crowdfund us doing
them that never happened I don't think
he cried well not Beyond it promoting
mug Club Mud Club like he always does so
why is he not permanently banned I mean
please let's just you know it's the
biggest evidence against his whole
thesis that like conservatives are
[__] squelched on YouTube I Can't
banned as much as him yeah yeah like
what the [__] they got this crazy victim
complex just stop being a baby dude you
know the [__] rules they're going to
enforce the rules that's what it is
stop it
you know
or don't or don't
we will not always says he's not going
to we will not stop except for the two
weeks when we're not allowed to upload
We Will Never Surrender except for when
we get a strike and and YouTube says
don't post
either
this is how he sees himself eh
uh the the Spartans were very homosexual
uh right I mean they [__] and also
they [__] kids I think too
didn't they that's what you uh yeah all
the Greeks did you said to him uh during
the Sam Cedar incident yeah
so I can see why he
you know identifies
I don't know that he [__] kids
right
how would I know that I hope he doesn't
watch it oh yeah no I hope he doesn't
sure
watch it
uh but uh there it is
Stephen Crowder getting fired up
[__] you YouTube
[__] you at YouTube rat
the ad is funny like nobody reads that
one like if you actually want someone to
read it don't tag at YouTube dummy like
what are you talking about
that [__] gets tagged probably like
literally a hundred thousand times a day
nobody's going through it that doesn't
work either such a coward Stephen coward
I love to talk to him I would actually
talk to him
well she didn't want him to interview
probably sure he's gonna probably not
happening be real open to that I thought
Ethan was a stand-up guy
mom
yeah I don't think that's happening I
thought Ethan was a stand-up guy
don't know what gave you that idea buddy
ah
well so sorry Crowder
so sorry
uh did you did we mention that you um
abused your wife
come up a few times yeah just wanted to
make sure that we don't forget that
yeah
right no
um you know I was watching clips of this
girl pharah on um the live yesterday for
members and people want more
here I'll show you guys this is the girl
from
Tick Tock that's how I know her pharah
khalidi
and she's been on fresh and fair and
she's been on whatever she actually even
debated Rolo Tony Brown town in brown
Town who's 53 years old and he's still
on these shows talking about hookup
culture he's The Godfather 53 bro we
have that clip in here too this guy's
gonna be Wheeling around the wheelchair
in the [__] convalescent home talking
about or the not
the old folks from home talking about
pickup culture and [__] out of bang
grannies
what are you afraid of Ian
uh here check this out after after this
we'll do the fika set
yeah position
um I'm a virgin oh [__] stop the cow
wait what'd you say I said I'm a virgin
stop the cap this man straight up has a
stop the cap button that he pushes in
front of their face
is that so embarrassing for him he could
just
like he could that's what I was thinking
yeah just say that right it's like
having his own Applause button where he
pushes it he's like
yeah it's not it's not adding anything
spec like Zach makes it special with the
sound bites thank you well and of course
it's not it's not beautiful it's not me
backing me up like
no but I'm in I'm in your brain you know
yeah wow you're in my wall his ass to it
he just spoke to himself it's
embarrassing that's gap it's like him
being like yo anyway and he's like that
was funny hey me that was funny joke I
I've said this before I'd love to give
them a master class I'd be more than
happy to sit them down show them how
everything works for free
yeah top dollar but you know just don't
pacing timing it's all about the timing
Myron what's up the cat it's all about
the timing Myron all right here it is
why why the air horn in there that again
no contacts where the air horn oh no
that was applicable that was me oh sorry
all right now you're confusing me boy
yeah yeah
you're not a virgin that was him or you
that was him okay I'm not doing it
anymore okay that one song
dude the record scratch kills me
all right let's actually watch this I've
paused it let's just watch the [__]
clip
again wait can you say it again I'm dead
ass yeah
version
another version come on
come on so the part that's really funny
to me about this
is they're obsessed with body count
obsessed and then when they find a girl
who's never had sex they're like no tell
us you're a liar you know you're a [__]
come on it's like this is this is what
you want
but then you can't believe it exists so
then
what is it you really want
emotions that's what we want
yo this chick's hilarious bro you don't
like gray humor yeah
funny by not being funny yeah
good analysis coconuts oh I see what
she's doing I see what she's doing
somebody else who's really funny without
drunk without me right yeah
uh she make she makes me laugh but she
not try oh
how'd she do that
I'm surprised Coconut's just not there
like drooling
so you're really Coconut's the only dude
who could get a lobotomy and be smarter
hmm
yes what do you all think y'all believe
it or not
I believe her I believe yeah absolutely
bear wait how old are you 23. wait but
you're the only fans
so hold on hold on it's almost like
taking pictures your pictures of
yourself isn't equivalent to like
putting a dick inside of you like it's
almost like you don't need one to do the
other yes I I know I'm just saying like
the activity could lead to you know
penetration at some point why
coconuts you're the dumbest [__]
alive he's correlating tooth you can say
that about anything you could be like
well obviously lunch will eat
like yes sir but they happen at two
different times a day and they're not I
don't eat what I have for lunch for
dinner it's not connected hold on hold
on you're telling me
that
you live in a house with a man
yeah he's my dad my brother and you
haven't had sex uh
one activity could lead to the other
uh
I'll tell you what man if you open his
head scooped out his brains and put a
coconut in there I think his the
processing power wouldn't would increase
[Music]
did you
use his toys
yeah I use like suctions
oh that's penetration so hold on
hold on hold on oh
my God
yeah
that's embarrassing I mean I mean do
this whole show about sex and you're
gonna expose like oh you're the problem
bro you can't you can't sexually please
him uh that one hurt yeah but I have a
question if you use a dildo you can
you're still a virgin if you haven't had
stuff because the concept of Virgin
not real in the
first Pacific happens and then boom it's
all done it's like there's obviously a
spectrum if like someone uses a dildo
someone could say that that is them
losing when you when you I don't know
physically when you jerk off are you not
a virgin when a when a teenager jerks
off for the first time is he he lost his
virginity like no obviously no yeah I
don't think so yeah I think it's having
sex with somebody well it's the
ambiguity of like also homosexual
relationships it's the especially in the
lesbian Community people like yeah he
defined it as penetration so okay if you
consider losing your virginity I guess I
would I would yeah yeah yeah it's all
subjective it is all subjective uh
what do we got here this is uh yeah the
line about the
what is this baby it holds your Alexa
you just it's like a just goes in there
I was saying I want a coconuts and
Barbados version one of these
the headset has his voice in it no just
um yeah that'd be kind of fire
coconuts what is the [__]
uh uh he also reminds me you know in the
second sounds of Lamb's Hannibal where
he's like serving him his own brain yeah
I sure do oh that's really good
oh God
yeah but uh every time this guy talks I
see why he stays quiet man it's just not
good situation when he talks penetration
at some point
did you say you use toys
yeah I use like suction oh
that's penetration
uh what
we gotta pull that we gotta pull that
Zach oh penetration you got it
I want to see the continuation
yeah he gets checked on that right
suction
[Music]
it just hits the clip I'm very picky
like someone please try to extrapolate
me from that honestly it was so extreme
that it was funny
because she's a virgin so he's what that
and and maybe am I interpreting is that
a certain type of Allah Akbar
is definitely meant to indicate like
unaliving yourself okay okay so I can I
can make that I mean I'll talk about
what we say every day when we pray right
we don't scream it out like it sounds
like it's being yelled and like anger I
guess that kind of yeah so I ever yell
that out y'all better duck
so the only
I wouldn't duck bro I would I would I
would grab you and say we go together
brother oh hell yeah
we'll make peace in the Middle East with
that
the only thing I can think of
is that this [__] thought
because she's a virgin that when you
Allah Akbar yourself or I don't know if
that's what I think you're thinking way
too advanced when you when you blow your
when you martyr yourself you go to
heaven and get a bunch of virgins right
yeah so he's like I'm ready to do it
I I think I don't know if you're giving
him that much but why why would he hit
it let me just clarify that because I
get [__] when I don't clarify that that
that's not actually a thing
what's not a thing like doing that and
then going to heaven and they're being
like Oh you okay thanks for the
clarification I don't think you need to
say that but yeah
yeah but also she has an Arab name have
we have we uh oh that's a weird another
shitty angle that he could be taking
yeah well I feel like it's inappropriate
but isn't it like suggesting that she
just shocked them
like dropped a Allah Akbar how does that
denounced shot he's meaning like they
dropped yeah I I feel like it's
inappropriate for even me to suggest
that but I think that's how we're
thinking she Dropped a Bomb
yeah I saw people suggest that when I
watched it that's [__]
what
oh that's a penetration
doesn't know what that is
why are you I mean it just hits the clip
I'm very picky okay
I'm sorry I just can't deal with that
see he does it in frustration I feel
like he's using it as like a he wants to
kill himself yeah or and everyone around
him yep
it it means uh the translation is
Allah's God is great right so maybe just
like
a virgin I don't [__] know
why don't you believe her why would I
lie I'm very because
sure yeah so many chat confirmed this
man who can confirm this
is
now it's it's it's it's astonishing
wait user 186 says that uh he banged you
number 20 says he's [__] you your
thoughts
um there's one other one with her that I
like of her owning Rolo Tony Brown town
and then we can we'll do the fika dude
this guy is such a loser bro look at him
what do you mean we do Rollo Tony God
damn it
for me romantic chemistry is incredibly
volatile it's not based on any
barometers of like oh he's in school he
has this career or anything so it could
just be random dude off the street 100 I
am not hypergamous at all you are so
hypergamous you won't have sex with a
guy until the guy is the guy that you're
looking of course and then if I had sex
with guys and then they made less than
men and you'd say oh because we broke up
it proves that none of those
interactions counted right I think the
very I think the fact that you are a
virgin right now just proves a point
that you're hyper like to a very high
degree the fact that I'm abstinent means
that I'm waiting for someone richer than
me no no hypergamy doesn't mean women
are bad did I say bad and I even imply
that hypergamy is just an algorithm it's
an evolutionary adaptation that women
have it's not a negative or positive
thing I'm not sure if it's an
evolutionary habitation I think the
reason women have historically been
hypergamous is because they were barred
from higher education so obviously the
average man was going to earn more than
them but by 2050 we're going to see a
total reverse
hypergly has nothing to do with money
I'm using the current definition of
hypergamy which is that women date
someone with a superior sociological or
monetary background
these guys are so dumb
and she is yeah I mean yeah
there was actually one where she's
owning Rolo where he was saying uh
ah there was another one of her owning
Rolo and I have a thing for for watching
Rolo get dunked on oh
just penetration yeah I'll be careful
scrolling that just want to point out
that Rolo's definitely dying his hair
110.
penetration
all right well whatever she's she's
great go check her out uh she tours
these podcasts and embarrasses these
guys with all that being said
we've saved the best for last
Sam has been in the laboratory
she has been preparing the fika
the footy figure for life
figure of life she has gone and done the
impossible apparently or we'll see
theoretically
the most disgusting vile [__] that any
of us have ever smelt or tasted
[Music]
is about to be prepared
and a scrumptious Style
that we can all eat and enjoy
[Music]
some say it couldn't be done
some still say it couldn't be done
yet we're here to try
here's Sam
with
thank you I get a little Margarita dish
is this just uh it is strawberry
daiquiri
very nice
chopsticks
wow
yeah I can use chopsticks I'm scared
though what that means
I'm not doing any Sashimi on my
don't you serve me no sashimi
girl am I not the only one trying this
right
okay
okay that's good that you survived that
I will say that I'm the one that has
allergic reactions to this [__]
so if anyone should be trying to get to
Dan
does any fish
what about for a gag
you nailed that one rich
all right Dan block me
that's rich Lux of course so here I've
got my Chopsticks farewell FICA fish uh
it's been nice
I see there's young lean back here
enjoying some FICA two Swedish Kings
right there who's this guy is that the
king that's the king we just came King
Carl Gustaf
calling a star I wonder if color good
stuff gets down with fika
probably
is that Ivan Drago on the other side yep
that's Dolph Lundgren and then he got
cancer last week no no no I think so
[__] wait what did he do this guy he was
the Russian in Rocky IV what did he get
canceled for cancer oh cancer I guess
that's canceled in a way yeah this one
God cancels you yeah God cancels you
that sucks
did he he didn't die he just has it yeah
no it's just battling yeah good good
luck brother
that shit's like Rocky you [__] you
know what I mean didn't he win yeah yeah
no he's locked he'd lost garage
[__] he killed Apollo yeah [__]
okay well trip yeah treat that cancer
like Apollo kill him
so as we wait here uh
meditate on
the importance of fika to the Swedish
people
and I think well
what is important in all of our Lives I
wonder
in my life
something like FICA that's important to
me penetration
is uh trying to find the [__]
still haven't found it
still looking
all right here comes the first dish
now I don't want to be the only one
tasting this [__]
oh my God
holy [__] dude are you serious right now
I'm serious right dude what the [__]
does so much I mean it looks amazing but
like oh my God no please I can't eat
that do you want me to tell you what it
is yes please this is Sir stroming in a
Yuzu ponzu sauce with cilantro pickled
serrano chili and a lemon piece on top
holy [__] and you ate this I did eat
that got a whole bite yes and how was it
I thought this one was totally fine I
can't do it who's eating this here I'm
gonna pass out the others look at the
chunk I mean it's such a big piece of
fish man good day to be a vegetarian huh
Sam did you try this this one okay the
only one thanks baby the only one who's
actually ever eaten any of this is Ian
so any anything of this
Zach took a bite I don't know if he held
it down though oh I spit it up that is
fragrant I mean even after all you
process that it is fragrant
I'm sure
yeah but I have to get pretty close to
it it's a lot it's a lot it's nothing
like no normal
with the peak of it bro I don't know
that I I can't I don't know I don't know
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I hate this I don't like this
bit
you have uh three more after this so
all right who's who's who's who's gonna
eat this
you're gonna do it Olivia I'm doing good
I'm going into okay good because I'm
allergic right so
we don't actually know that do we every
time I've eaten it I've broken out
you didn't eat it you like it's licked
it what happens if I'm gonna eat it I'm
gonna drop dead
you were getting rashes from all kinds
of [__] a lot
I just tried to pick it up and the two I
thought it was two separate pieces it's
to kind of cut pieces connected my skin
no there's here look then
skin on the bottom and it's slimy
looking oh no
make sure you get all of it together it
makes it easier Ian you eat flavor
I don't think I can do this I swear to
God I don't think I can do it the pepper
the salon cilantro the lemon
oh no no all right who's going first
I'll go first all right good man
I can smell it dude it is stinky it is
stinky wouldn't you play with it a
little bit
that
oh
[Music]
that is
gave it a billion effort but he ejected
it
what happened is the flavor still there
I I think I just have PTSD from right I
think it's a mental wall it smells
though well what was the taste like oh
it's my mouth it's a little spicy from
the jalapeno
but I I taste the [__] Fish Man
I can smell it more smell it now that I
played with it a little bit oh
I'm so sad oh I got it I got a decent
whip it at that time you guys were being
kind of rude to Sam in my opinion yeah
Samsung I mean no disrespect
ively
what it is Kim Kardashian I work and I
work and I work
it stinks man just get just eat it you
eat it [__] I don't eat fish all right
who's next stop I'm allergic to let's
keep it going Olivia are you going for
it
[Music]
one bite keep it healthy and whatever
you got this you're a champion
of this ready
what is that for that's not gonna help
for me to literally spit
who oh okay I was like that ain't big
enough
man my body isn't letting me put it
closer to my mouth go ahead you got this
girl you are in command
yes Olivia put it in she's chewing she
doesn't look happy with it at all but
she's chewing is she is she she's yeah
she's spitted out didn't last very long
deal with it Sam I love what you did
with that
yeah
I agree and it looks it looks amazing if
any other fish you know
that that can't be okay to eat the thing
because all the flavors are so
incredible except for the fish yeah
right like I know that if that were on
like an albacore tuna I would eat the
[__] out of it
yeah I can't like I love you Sam so much
you're so beautiful and so amazing I
just sadly don't like FICA fish is this
the one that you like Sam or was it a
different oh no so this is the As Good
As It Gets oh
yeah I had to uh taste test this one as
well it's not that bad it's not it's a
mental game again Sam no disrespect to
you I apologize I don't know I just I
can't is anyone else gonna do this you
nobody else a b no more come on baby
okay
it's like get my beard out man come on
bro back me up dude Lena would do it
probably would if you do it I'll do it
I'm only doing it if a b does it what
what is this I can't do I told Olivia I
wouldn't puke I'm definitely gonna puke
so
oh [__] come on cam anybody you know
what
I'll break my vegetarian streak for this
oh really I will maybe I'll give you
okay well do you have yours baby you can
saw you Cam okay the chance that you
even swallow it seems pretty slim
basically I feel like I could this is my
toxic trick is that I feel like I could
eat the figures let's see cam can eat it
all who should I have you can't mine
it's tiny okay
hold on how small because if it's small
I want it
it's really small
yeah I'll run it to Camp
thank you very much so Ethan are you
gonna have it if I have it because I
want to see you eat it I'm going to try
it okay hell yeah
just do it man just go
thank you
I mean again it doesn't look that bad on
the camera
but that's got to be a slimy ass nasty
[__] how did you prepare this to
him
committed she's nowhere near Mike
showing
he's you guys are overreacting did you I
have a feeling okay hold on did you ever
participate in the fika
I smelled it I never put it in my mouth
well so you don't have that Association
I smelled it I got my face off to it I
think it's fine I think it tastes pretty
good
God there you go we got a pretty good
Sam how did you prepare this
so I let it marinate in the Yuzu ponzu
sauce overnight and I put a little bit
of the juice on the plate and then I
just slice the rest and put it on top
very simple if you never if you've ever
had yellowtail jalapeno that was the the
inspo this is not cooked
no
but it's it's fermented in the yeah I
mean when when what does that mean
Sashimi
fish you don't have to cook it yeah
every other time we've had it it's never
been cooked it was right out of the can
once sitting out for a day whoa and it's
been it was refrigerated
I don't know about all that [__] it's
wicked salty that's that's my only if it
was yellowtail any other type of fish
salmon even a like a bad fish that just
wasn't FICA and Sam made it I would eat
that up we just have such Why did you
give me such a big one though they're
all that stuff
do me a favor
please
[__] it I just gotta do this shut up man
you try it I don't need fish yeah well
exactly so so who are you to even say
anything if I didn't even look at that
totally do it
it's really not that bad
I know how bad it's going to be it's
just salty it's weird you had you have
Zach and Olivia's reactions to go off of
both of them are fairly
it's not gonna kill you okay I know it's
not gonna kill me I'm the only one that
has allergic reactions to it
you got this huge
dude just do it
bro I swear to God I don't know if I can
do this down the Hat you can do it why
is so much skin just hit the fish yeah
it's fish I mean yeah
hit the fish bro just hit the fish
hit the fish hit the fish just hit that
fish hit the fish a little bit on the
candle oh come on and then hit that fish
let me cook it a little bit the puffer
that's gonna make it worse that's gonna
make it worse get a nice sear on it
definitely I'm gonna count down I'm
gonna count down you're gonna do it
you're gonna get that like no you're not
Wick taste now I'm gonna do it oh hit
the fish
[__] I hate this [__] just say school
and then eat it
here's a gravy dish
foreign
Dr Pepper collab I'm going to look at
the gravy dish yeah that's where the
feet is going
straight onto my chicken
all right [__] my [__] [__] my tight
little [__] let's go let's go [__]
put the Goliath up my ass
I love that hunger's like the toys I use
have names like Goliath and the giant
the the colossal
you're killing time here
he goes
the toys I use
got name like
the blue whale
the bronchiosaurus
[Music]
supernova
hit the fish
I've just
[__] baby how are you not gonna do this
baby it's not fair if I'm gonna do this
you're gonna do this I just went in
there to help Sam the next one smells so
[__] awful bro
okay I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it
does anyone have an EpiPen
I just want to make sure we have an
EpiPen because if we don't have an
EpiPen I can't do it it's not safe
uh yeah we we have one
we'll see I got one in my in my backpack
do you have any Anti-Venom
yeah I got a lot of that too
[Music]
there you go oh there you go
it goes
okay Cam now's not the time to be joking
about down the Hat I've been waiting to
hit you with that other hook bar as soon
as you bite it
that's not gonna help
here it is it's in the mouth
[Laughter]
not at all loaded up is it ready to go
nothing to wait on now here we go and oh
it's in he's biting
to it yeah
let them cook oh come on SO Primal
that's my garbage that is so so primal
[Music]
God [__] me in the [__]
[Laughter]
well nobody should eat that I don't know
why it exists I'm so glad that fish the
fish are all dying
no we love the fish
Here Comes round two oh wow that looks
lovely this one actually smells really
good all right
that one at least looks like
there's more to dampen the flavor yeah
um this one I didn't like it at first
but then I tweaked it so I think it
might be better is there was somebody on
here no no I'll say this I I put enough
time to taste the flavors
you did a good job of diminishing it
it's still there though it's still there
subtly enough I think in all of these
it's still there
it's almost impossible to get rid of
that it's such intense salt like it's
just you can't it's just got that ass
like I don't drive it it's like salty
ice cream yeah
so this next one is uh spicies are
strumming over crispy rice with smashed
avocado and pickled serrano chili and
good eel sauce so this is crazy because
I will get the [__] down with that if it
was anything else literally like that
looks amazing beautiful thank you thank
you thank you for the first piece I
tried this one but you said you didn't
like it I tried it after I tweaked it
and is it I think it's better and have
you tried this one I tried the pre uh
tweaked version how do you feel about it
pre-tweek uh there's definitely some
room for improvement okay are you
talking now when you say room for
improvement are you just talking about
the dish or the fika
the the way of masking the thought that
it is FICA fish uh needed some help uh
so hopefully that I don't like the sound
of a little better but
I don't know Zach you want to give it a
go yeah I'm going to hit it
go ahead I mean it looks better than the
last one you know
I'm gonna let you eat that first Zach's
put it in
he's crunching he seems unbothered
actually
relatively unbothered by Zach
he's crunching he's chewing he's
thinking
is he going to abort he's got it this
time you got it dude you got it like
it's ready for swallowing at this point
you're good
he's got a thumbs up thumbs up yo there
you go oh there you go
well done well done I was it's
definitely not as Extreme as the first
one
it's still there I'm not gonna lie what
are you able to appreciate the flavor
profile of the fika fish at all with it
being the worst part it's the worst part
it's the smell it gets in your
it's just vile yeah a [__] herring fish
oh they all die we love the hair what do
they use Herring for other than fika
bro delhi's have [__] creamed Herring
yeah I'm saying it's all nasty yeah
nobody needs herring you know the the
whole like masking part that you guys
are talking about that I feel like is
the whole purpose with the Swedish dish
because they really tried to hide that
[__] they cut it in tiny pieces and [__]
so it's like a game to just make it
taste as little of its original flavor
as possible sounds like a really cool
food why eat it then exactly well I'm
not the main person or audience who eats
it guys I've got this crazy idea
the dude who invented the zipper he goes
okay now on to my next idea uh he
modified
he goes let's make the most vile
disgusting [__] freak [__] that you
can't even open in your house or your
house will be cursed for a week and then
let's take it and try to make it not
taste anything like that
um
and that's the game
do you like locks Ethan no you don't
like smoked salmon no I don't see I love
that you are you what the [__] you don't
like water I tried telling people I'm
not a Jew leave me the [__] alone
everybody's saying oh you're Jewish
whatever really it might be on to
something
all right so Olivia your turn
[Laughter]
it's not bad Zach eight thousand yeah I
know this one will probably it's
probably pretty good by the way when
love arrives his ass is eating all this
nasty [__] yeah you're eating a food
there's no more food though
oh you just mean like in general eating
the whole thing sorry you have to you
have to I mean no no it's easier if you
bite through it I think it's gonna be
harder yeah you have to all in because
if you it's not gonna it's not gonna
break apart elegantly it's gonna be a
whole nightmare whether it be ugly than
all in my mouth all right if you want to
buy it in half I I'm I think not but go
for it
all right
all right so is the fact that you
gagging making you gag more because I
know you have a puke thing
oh it stinks so bad smell it then
I don't like put your nose right up on
it yeah it's in my like mustache nothing
no I smell it
I don't know it it's it's tough because
it tastes like the the stuff that's
obviously not that tastes so good it
does I won't say that it smells good but
like I do
like the heavily fermentedness in the
context of something like that I I get
where they're coming from
I still don't think I would like it but
Dan I can't stand it it's so easy for
you to sit here and be like oh no I get
it you asked
so eat it Dad is jealous of me it's true
okay Cam your turn
see cam gets it he's all in cams Cam's
like the doodle will eat any damn thing
not true at all not true at all he's
literally a vegetarian until today
Cam's chilling he's thinking he's
um he's from New England he knows
Seafood you know that salty Seafood yeah
Vibe he's on that he's struggling a
little bit huh he's struggling a little
bit it's a lot but yeah
I'm not gagging or anything I don't know
it's it's gross but it's not the most
disgusting thing how does it write to
the first dish you add honestly the the
first dish was a lot easier to swallow
because it was smaller but this I don't
like the sound of uh it's gross I uh
prefer the first one I think oh my God
yeah really
I think so it has accurate like this one
more so I feel like the the avocado and
the the jalapeno
um
I feel like the rice cake helps with the
consistency that I will say this is good
for me I can guarantee I'm not gonna
want to eat anything for the rest of the
day very true there you go that's lovely
so [__] disgusted with this right now
file
yeah shaking
all right one second
yeah I don't think maybe that's why
people Swedish Swedish people are skinny
yeah is their food's terrible and love
you said this is like a northern Swedish
thing right not where you're the problem
is it looks really good
just think it's it's spicy just think
it's spicy too spicy tuna on there I'm
not pretending [__] dude I can smell
[__] on my goddamn food yeah the smell
is brutal it's very bad
just go just go man
we got it you got this
you so have this
thank you don't be shy thank you for the
backup material I'm the uh
all right here I go
how much
Bottoms Up
here we go
taking a bite first bite here we go
all righty here comes the choo choo
train oh and by the way there's a stink
emanating now from the trash can that I
already spit the first round in
right how many of these are there this
is the last one right two more two more
you gotta just power through it
I can't
dive in there it goes and down match
it's so big gauge the mass specification
the chewing
I I don't I it's too big but I can't do
this [__]
oh there it is
[Music]
thank you for tuning in to the H3
podcast
I definitely think the bigness of the
actual pieces of fish [__] you because
in the Swedish dish they're tiny dude
they cut those [__] down big
time it was pretty small over in our
kitchen right now looking for a chaser I
think what's the little um wait let me
just say real quick I play the Allah
don't don't blame Zach for that
also if this is cut and posted as a
highlight without the previous segment
uh giving the context that's going to
seem pretty insane so
that's how we roll baby that's how we
roll I guess you know we're crazy over
here we're wild
I see a little piece of information from
uh from Dan over there that Herring are
a good source of vitamin D
yeah the random a B vitamin D's not
random AV back to the day not worth it
love which Swedish table you're sitting
at are you sitting at a Carl Gustav
stable or you're sitting at a PewDiePie
stable uh oh damn that's kind of hard
[__] you actually split my Idols pretty
well here
um right because you're gonna stay loyal
to pewd or you're going to stay loyal to
uh yeah
[Music]
I don't know like
that actor uh that very well
um man he is a legend I can't answer
this bro I don't know but I don't know
if I want to continue this no
you gotta try the Swedish one though I
mean Sam worked so hard on this she
slaved in the kitchen all day yesterday
you try it then Dan you destroyed our
apartment with this uh destroyed our
apartment oh
at least we can show it off you know a
little keeps saying there's supposed to
be smaller bites you're giving us like
fat sushimi bites there's not that much
in here it's a tiny it's like this big
and it looks pretty small
here put it down I can show the audience
I mean you can't see it it looks like a
swamp looks like a [__]
this one is
cauliflower puree with
the little piece of heat strumming brown
butter sauce with
so how big is the soup strawberry you
should go ahead go ahead yeah you're
here I'll repeat
um I'll hold this this is cauliflower
puree with sir strumming and crispy
Capers and brown butter sauce on top
delicious it sounds beautiful
no it minus it looks the turd nuggets on
a fika fish it looks delicious you know
Artisan even
all right go ahead Zach it looks like
it's from that movie the menu yeah it
does which by the way that movie [__]
with my mind
um all right could I do some sound bites
while you're doing this on Dan's
computer
uh sure and you're asking permission
go for it why'd you ask his permission
okay [__]
because uh you know he's he's in he's a
he's a master of his craft delicate
artist yeah
are you a delicate artist Zach yes okay
bitterville
Zach went in for a clean bite
probably real oh no no it's accidentally
why into the little girl
he's spitting it out into a little
coffee cup yeah
but didn't you hear Sam say it's just a
tiny piece
you taste it man
you taste that [__]
I'm not tasting anything I'm out yeah
such a [__] and if you eat it I'll eat
it you cannot say [__] you can't say
you're infringing on my beliefs right
now okay but I'm just saying you can't
say [__] I'm gonna speak to HR the
cauliflower puree was magnificent Sam
that flavor was fantastic it was just
the uh
the the the [__] overwhelming of
rotting [__]
garbage
there you go all right Olivia
he's shaking she looks not she's not
gonna be able to swallow this one
I was shot now dude
the mashed potatoes were excellent but
the consistency does not help it's just
a gooey rice
the real question is can cam eat it so
far he's undefeated yeah
here we go
Down the Hatch let's go man
Bottoms Up
it's not your fault
any time now it's like when you're about
to jump into like jump rope
it's happening
she's preparing
lots of hesitancy she's thinking about
it here she goes she took just a little
sip all right I don't even think she got
the freak of fish
she just got a little Nick off the front
mashed potatoes is hidden
again it lives in the cauliflower puree
yeah did you Sam did you cook it into
the puree
the brown butter sauce is is absolutely
Delight it's divine all right cam let's
see if you can if you can be the soul
Victor here okay this [__] is going to
do no problem everybody scoop it school
here goes it's like eating an oyster
yeah I scooped it down like an oyster oh
even cam is grimacing now it's the
consistency yeah that one's weird he
threw it back though yeah I ate it but
it was [__] weird I'm not doing it
let's just keep it moving this show it's
just gonna be forever I'm sorry
everybody you know such a coward [__]
you cannot say [__] you're a [__]
coward for being a vegetarian it's not
it's that's bravery it's bravery do we
have uh takes bravery to be a vegetarian
do we have milk
mouthwashing the house by any chance now
Cam's asking for a mouthwash I mean well
my brother it does smell like [__] now
damn it
don't you guys have any don't you care
about my children at all
two young boys that need their dad alive
in the
in the camera shot it looks quite
delightful don't you think has kids I
had a really long day there's no
babysitter tonight if I get sick also
lazy
I don't leave the house usually
how nice that looks
Gourmet dude I'm dragging it out and I
know it's just not that interesting to
watch but I can't I can't do it
tell yourself I can do this
it'll change your mindset just say it no
I'm not gonna tell myself until you make
it
manifest manifest the courage
[__] I mean what are you gonna see just
give me spit it out I mean Olivia
she tried or you may love it what if you
like this one that's not happening
Different Strokes for different folks
this one might
this might be your new favorite dish yep
you can see the fish hairs look at this
chairs yeah
yeah I've never met a hairy fish before
Airy fish named my proctologist
yeah you can see it
so thick
auto focus is struggling on the speaker
fish
guys I'm sorry I'm not doing it I'm not
doing it I'm sorry wow I'm just not
doing it I'm saying no I'm sorry guys
I have to I just I have to do this for
myself
you know there's listen listen I do a
lot for this show I'm not doing this
check please thank you all for tuning in
I give it all to the for this show I'm
not I just can't well at least can we
take a look at the last let's just move
it along yeah let's just all right let's
take a look at the fourth dish and maybe
here can you agree right now that you'll
eat no either this one or the fourth
well wait until you see the fourth what
does that means bring it out maybe this
one won't seem that bad you don't get to
talk to me I I feel like that's illegal
for you to say that to me right now
don't talk to me I can't stand Dan based
off of mine based off of my beliefs
here's Ian reporting from yesterday Sam
was cooking
uh these masterpieces
I'm I'm walking into the house
can you see that [__] stinks in here
oh my God
[__] can you not smell this anymore
bro
oh my God hold the [__] phone why are
what's with all these dumbass buttons
here double click the window
I did this one just hit the green one in
the top left that button this
yeah
stupid ass Max dumb stupid idiot Mac
hate Apple
[Music]
I'm I'm walking into the house
and it's [__] stinks in here
oh my God
can you not smell this anymore
oh my God I don't smell anything
it is so foul in here
oh my God
I smell nothing it is disgusting oh do
we have any footage of you cooking Sam
oh you're editing it all right let me
see the last one
again presentation is great
um
so this is the classic uh ficaway yeah
that's the Swedish style this like this
I'll eat the last one oh yeah this one
looks interesting so this one is no
shock uh Dan
so this one is a little like Swedish
flatbed just flat bread cracker with two
potato slices so strumming sour cream
red onion and chives this is great like
this is like this looks beautiful and uh
I mean if it wasn't for the
I would I would tear this up dude
I I gotta say you hit hit the nail on
the head that looks just like you and
the amount it's like a small version of
what we get
very good thank you
the amount of fish looks correct to you
it's like a whole filet uh I can't
really see my uh usually you shot them
up super tiny I think it might be
slightly bigger than usual yeah
and it's small it's small have you tried
this dish before love
uh no [__] no well you will save a camp
for love
I don't know what that did [__] all
right I I'm gonna try this one I'm gonna
you know just to give it put it into
proportions I have been at places where
Sue strumming has been prepared maybe
twice my whole life like this is not
something you do
if you're below the age of 60. yeah
yeah because it's like depression food
yeah all right Zacky
oh you don't like the look of that I
thought this is the nicest looking one
so far the sour cream is you know I'm
weird with yogurts and creams you could
scoop it off I'd be fine with that the
sour cream is Gonna Save you I think
here sour cream in the onion seems like
it'll cover the yeah taste the most just
pretend that's what I've been saying I
think literally the sour cream and the
onions are made to just absorb any
flavor right
are you want me to go do it Bud let's
see it give us a school
school
there we go how do you say I love
it's like shares so it's not accurate
but it's called
dip some skull
back one bite
oh he's out into the tiny cup my cup is
killing me for fun
how's that cup smell dude oh God
ah
that's even nastier than like a dip cup
you see when people smell it yeah that's
the worst thing
was the problem the cream or the fish or
everything it was everything
wait did you like this one Sam and Ian
uh I actually haven't tried this one oh
okay
let's get you in one please
she didn't make this one until this
morning I think can we get Ian to try it
do we have to do that
come here
here you can have half of mine I'm not
gonna eat the whole thing we could cut
it in half
because there's two Dobbs to sour cream
so that's perfect for Ian here I'll cut
it in half
so excited to do that was the worst man
that was the worst one
river is down my spine is
perfect
Olivia Europe
has been subjected to the susroman so
many times I feel so bad
well he hasn't tried this one do we want
me to
this is the worst one you said Zach I'm
weird with like creams and [__] I think
it's I think it's a Zack issue it's by
the way a jar of mayonnaise okay right
that's not it's not cream technically
creamy I could give this to a
well you gotta take yours to go deliver
that
yeah Olivia's going for it
um I'm not gonna carry it by hand give
me the thing
here we go
okay School
room are we ready
yo
dinks bro just smelled my finger huge
mistake when eating Slim strawman Never
Smell Your Finger go ahead
Olivia's going in
stick your finger put it all in there
chewing thoughtfully she's gagging a
little bit more this time than any other
better than the previous oh
she got way further that time though
it's when the fish hits you right yeah
nasty here's the thing is
I loved it besides the fact that's all
these they're all so good really damn
you're incredibly talented literally I'm
so sorry none of my none of my reactions
are a basis on your cooking okay amazing
and fantastic and I love this is very
exciting Ian is about to uh does Cam
have one or no I do yeah
[Applause]
I think I just like to visit Sweden
someday so I'm really trying to choke it
down now all right
School score do it for a moment call
moving moment Doper movement uh-oh
this is not a good one uh-oh I just
don't like the texture of the cracker
crackers oh the crackers the problem is
for the cracker
disgusting crackers all around it's just
weird textures cracker oh brother
I am not gonna farewell yeah the fish
really starts to come through he's
getting it down though he's doing it
he's doing his job he's having a hard
time this is a gross one I will say this
is [__] gross this is Cam's biggest
challenge yeah in fact is he gonna
swallow it
he is going to swallow it yeah I got it
it's gone it's gone
I wouldn't expect it this is the buff
the tough one huh
all right let's see what you got Ian the
cracker is disgusting oh wait Ian
doesn't have a camera because that's
what they're smoking yeah actually here
I'll come over there oh good
Ian stepping in front of the camera what
a guy
we'll do it together okay
uh
that is a funny idea that is a funny
idea but no
no
should we do that should we wrap our
arms a little over yours is bigger if
you eat that one
oh wait no we feed ourselves like this
yeah okay okay ready three two one
School
oh
scroll
no for fun
you got this you got this you're a
champion come on
[Laughter]
Thursday
oh my God
you tried though oh I'm holding my
breath but then I know when you breathe
the FIFA hits you yeah that one is just
straight fika dude hell [__] no it's
awful hell you know I was gonna say
Swedish hate Sweden hates you now but
just one one percent of Sweden they eat
just the Boomers just hates you know
yeah
probably
is that it's time that was that's all
shout out last one very good thank you
very much all done well done they all
look uh delicious so the presentations
flavors were Immaculate no literally the
palette was so incredible
[Music]
Ethan's still struggling back there
oh
there's some mouthwash in the bathroom I
believe I'm cloroxing everything around
me in my I keep saying it's in my
mustache like this oh yikes yeah that's
gonna linger the worst part is you're
gonna be burping that oh I am I already
am yeah
sorry to say Ian what did you think of
the last one there any thoughts um oh my
camera's not working
um
it wasn't that bad but it's I'm having
uh flashbacks to the burping and that's
what's throwing me off because I know
it's definitely the worst part I know
it's gonna stay with me
I got my wasn't that bad though
I think what your advantage is because
you had coveted V1 here we go you had
that covered one here come the action no
no no no no I'm not bringing you down
you think I'm juicing I'm not I'm not
here I'm not breaking you down by any
means I'm just saying it might have
tainted
you know that covered one you're calling
me you think I'm like the Barry Bonds of
uh the Barry Bonds of Pika fish I think
it's just European the hunger FF the
Lance well no 100 FF is the Barry Bonds
of butthole
um
you're like the uh
this man's on three rounds of covid
bear Foul Play
that'll play you're juicing like Mark
Maguire yeah
what do you want me to play dance over
my shoulder asking me to press this
why do you want me to press the
different perspective
oh
kind of weird now put that phone down
wait just in time for Father's Day right
there no no you're
good oh just black different
perspectives don't need to be switching
to any of this you want this bag no
we're at a mouthwash
weird
well oh
just to watch that mouth manually I gave
him some toothpaste to stick on his
finger
oh ow like a kid at a sleepover
I want to go home that was literally me
my parents picked me up from Sleepaway
Camp
me too really I hated yeah I went to
sleep over once and um I pretended to
have a upset stomach me all the time
really oh look at that yeah
about you
I used to ask to stay a little longer be
like maybe could I stay a couple days
yeah maybe the whole weekend for a
sleepover or a Sleepaway Camp
sleepover
I always wanted to go to sleep away camp
never could that was sleep away camp
that's what Olivia was talking about
right yeah I was in the bathroom Sirens
oh okay
I was a counselor at Camp not Sleepaway
it was like a daycare you were a
counselor were you when the creepy ones
I taught uh oh my my activity was a
movie Magic oh what yeah what does that
mean it was just like the movie portion
so I gotta have the kids make like
storyboards or
um just like they have a camp counselor
recording a bunch of kids what's weird
about that dude why do you gotta make
everything so perfect no I gotta make
everything I remember I wonder if I
could find it the Sleepaway Camp that my
parents picked me up from the day after
I got there I I did the rock star the
rock star portion of the camp you got to
like choose your medium I guess and they
were like I was crying the whole day
they knew that I was leaving after like
that day so the counselors were like
Olivia why don't you like get in and why
don't you sing your song like you can
record it so that we can have it on the
CD that we like burn at the end of camp
and
um I was just sobbing crying all day
they were trying to get me to drink
water I refused to drink water and
there's a recording of me singing on top
of a karaoke track to do you believe in
magic and I'm crying the whole time I'm
singing it and you can tell because
sometimes I'll take like a breath and
I'll be like
and it is I need to find it
you might need to show show this on the
show yeah bro my sister came in clutch
when I was there love you Al
yeah she she was like no no you don't
understand she needs to call my mom she
needs to go home
uh Ethan is still like puking or
something I I just hear the water
running a bunch I think he's just oh got
his mouth under the fountain
huh
get some jams going damn music
kick out the jams Jam music do you
believe in magic yeah do you believe in
magic I think Ali and AJ had just
dropped a cover of that
of channeling them hey you know
[Music]
oh yo Mr breast you know I know him
my favorite YouTuber Mr brust
[Music]
ER oh my God Jesus
blood splatter [__] CSI scene
what happened
yeah yeah what happened I ran to the
bathroom in a panic and started throwing
water in my mouth and then did someone
finish the
the mouthwash just now
not me I could use some
I got edge up if anybody wants that
wash it down with some headship
okay that last one was was vile did you
even try to mask it or is that just
straight fika no that's the sweet EST
way I just I did it exactly so that's
straight out of the can yeah yeah oh
well no [__] Wonder was so well
that's like the classic way to serve it
that yeah that is the that's the way the
swedes do it I thought they like boiled
it didn't just take one bite of that's
the one that I wanted the burps are so
bad Ian the cooking process is being
installed for like a half a year the
burps are awful
I just had the rice cake one but I keep
burping it up
yeah so
the last one I held my breath didn't
taste anything the texture I'm chewing
it's fine but I know the minute that I
breathe it's gonna hit me like a
like a tsunami do you want a sodi as a
chaser
I that's probably a good idea you want a
Saudi
on it
Kim's got it yeah
I'm feeling bad for me I guess oh thank
you that's quick that was quick Olivia
yep thank you baby
following an hour footsteps that last
one was the worst one although I didn't
try the squishy nasty one I knew that
one was gonna
I was gonna puke if I did that one
how'd you like it Ian you weren't even
phased by that [__] like I said it
wasn't too bad but um
I just know what will happen later
loves my cooking
well you're raw dog the whole fish so
I was struggling last night though when
she was in The Test Kitchen find the
rest of the rock it is so big of both of
you to give up your apartment to the
smell of piece of fish it was a treat
for our cats
the smell alone was like a sensory
overload yeah here's what we're doing
love you're moving here
we have a can of fika and we're gonna
[__] your whole life back in together
I already tried to eat it though and I
was punished so badly I got [__]
juice all over oh that's right yeah I
guess he opened it ignoring that yeah oh
yeah that was awesome I feel like I've
already done my part no I
don't know
I'm I'm just I'm become like racist
against swedes
that's not right that's not right so I
got to put you through
Swedish fika torture no I did my part
dude filet
filet Pika no all right let's move on
let's just forget that this ever
happened please
good job well done presentation was
amazing
and uh what can I say you're you're
great
can we go home now
uh no no Zach you gotta wait till the
show's over
I mean you could go home if you're
actually sick oh spurbs I don't know
what to do we got Tums
um I think so I can give you something I
would love some Toms
I'm trying to breathe the flavor off
dude I'm done I'm done with fika [__]
thank God I'm not doing I'm not eating
any more of that
I'll make other people eat it but I'm
not you know I only use one can we have
two more cans
you hear that love two more cans I don't
deserve this I don't deserve this hey
bro do it or or else I'm gonna send you
guys back to Sweden well oh [__] well if
you guys do something crater with it
I'll try it of course I'm just kidding I
want anything I won't force you to do it
no no I'll do it
oh
oh let's move on here's a dude driving
into a shopping mall crying love that go
King cleanser
um
get out of the way
[Applause]
oh
excuse me
God damn bro come through
my iPhones available
so
okay first of all I didn't like seeing
that kid have to run that everyone is
okay everyone's okay everyone's great
okay because that would have been really
[__]
but other than that I think this person
thought their car was going to explode
or something when they hit them all
you know they only hit it going like
five miles per hour it's kind of like a
leisurely cruise through the mall
is there a story do we have any
background on this try to look into it
yeah Olivia found one article but it
wasn't English Chinese and I had to
translate it and it was pretty short but
the thing on Reddit said that a guy's
girlfriend broke up with him the actual
article that I read said that it was
during covid someone had lost their job
and and he this was potentially the
result of that I think he just wanted to
change his self-implant yeah yeah I
think he just got some errands yeah you
remember you never been in a rush
it was late to work I do sound that way
every morning
now well here's a good driver unlike
that last one
this guy knows how to park a car
and that's what the [__] I'm talking
about [__] like a club
Kathy's about to go buy some groceries
right now
dude that's the best it's hard to find a
spot
that was [__] amazing
uh
he's like all right I'll be right back
sweetheart I'm gonna go grab some things
you want anything from the store
[Laughter]
this is [__] awesome
oh yeah man that's good
that's some good [__] right there
brother tell you what Ethan you want
some Tums it definitely helps no I
didn't swallow any so I'm not having any
of the crazy burps oh man I just need to
get how are you doing you okay I'm fine
yeah it's just the burps are just it's
just the taste Revisited just a little
rice cake
the rice cake was hard just it was very
stale because I imagine she cooked it
yesterday
well no it was supposed to be crispy
like fried I know that but it was meaty
oh okay I see what you're saying yeah
you want to do this uh I would love to
do the PowerPoint
what it'll take like 30 minutes is that
is that 30 minutes how long we've been
going down uh we're going on through oh
you know what let's save it because I
want to do the it's Bryce this guy's my
favorite yeah yeah ELO might get a kick
out of it too so okay
so this guy I found him on my like
Instagram reels page and I was like yo
this is [__] crazy Bryce Savage He's
33 years old
and
I'm not necessarily making fun of him
because
you know anyone who's out there living
her their passion I think is uh
admirable
right but what I will say
is I am not laughing
so here I'll just give you a little
taste
of a banger is it always the shortest
girls that have the biggest attitudes
[Music]
all right is it just me or is it always
is it my favorite it's just me it's my
favorite is the way he starts them
the whole thing to me I was just caught
off guard by like the way he's dressed
the way he's looked he's a little bit
too old to be participating in this kind
of thing but he's thinking his dream
it's the uh sleeveless Aerosmith shirt
for me right but that's and it is that
it's like the mix of like this classic
rock and roll thing mixed with like the
and again I'm not trying to make fun of
Bryce but this [__] sucks
he's like Axel Rose
[__] music I've ever heard it's his
deep side part
you haven't never noticed the freckles
have the biggest attitudes it's just him
he's like a Batman Begins version of
Brett Michaels I think
the best part is the introductions he
does is it always the shortest girls
that have the biggest attitudes
and then and then he literally says
what he said he he literally sings what
he said I like that he include the Emoji
there too God damn it how am I supposed
to watch these if every time I open it
it's automatically muted and then I can
never watch the beginning yeah
Instagram's player sucks shortest girls
that have the biggest attitudes
that's what you just said
he has more little literal ones yeah he
got more specific he needs to get his
thesis across
he said short girls by five is not that
short yeah what did he mean by that well
he's saying five five or a girl five
five is not that short yeah yeah it's
like average yeah it's average
girls that have the biggest attitudes
I guess five two would have sounded
better he's five two with a little
latitude Yeah by five is like average
but he's saying that if you're five five
you have a little attitude oh
interesting so that's average five two
when you've got a big attitude no no no
he's not saying that yeah that's what he
says he says she's got a little attitude
like she's got a little attitude but not
the biggest attitude
no but
true he starts it off by saying that so
so according to your theory then he's
going to say he's gonna have another
verse about a short girl with a big
attitude a big attitude
she's three nine she's a little attitude
every verse is a different height
she's three nine and she's like Osama
bin Laden
the shorter the [__] up they are
there's always the shortest girls that
have the biggest attitudes
[Music]
guys but she likes some girls too
yo
[Music]
yo is this what real love feels nope
different versions of explaining the
same song I just sent another one that's
the same song Oh with a different intro
he goes into more detail oh fire okay
all right I gotta I gotta be quick on
that this one unmute button
I got to be the fastest unmute button in
the the girl that's this tall but she's
got an attitude about this tall check
this out
[Music]
oh I like this version better I was
hoping for more details but it he can he
a deeper a little less information if
anything
he's a size nine shoe
bad hands in her
acrylic
her nail polish is Sparkle too
is this what little girls are like oh no
proven by the high school
Little Women they're such flames
fat guy with the fat headed dude
he hates you a good way
bad guy with the fat attitude he hates
guys but his fat is like a brood like a
Jew
yeah that beats fire that's literally
his beat
here we go
great hair what did you ever notice that
the fattest guys have the bomb ass
hairlines
fat guy with the great hairline here
she's fatter it but his hairline gets
better
fat guy even fatter attitude
it's hard on the Fly you know
this guy obviously invested a lot of
time and lyrics
let's he's got a whole bunch of him
though see
so that one's pretty good
this is the original video I sent this
is the one that blew my ass out
looking face but this one's [__]
great it's like they all have the same
premise too well with a really innocent
looking face but whenever she opens her
mouth it's always like a dirty joke or
thought coming out yeah I did well check
this out yo
that's just what you said
every all of them all of his songs are
she's this but she's that like the first
line is always the same it's awesome
the best isn't he
I love that he's following his dreams I
want to jam with him man
yeah
you guys are dream collab we're all with
a really innocent looking face but
whenever she opens her mouth it's always
like a dirty joke or I just I imagine
this guy who's 33 trying to make up like
18 year olds for sure
he's like yo babe
are you into like alternative music well
then check this out
have you ever met a girl
who's got like big old titties but uh
tiny little heart
she's got a big tits but a tiny little
heart
her titties juggle like them
my heart is ticking when I fall
she's such a [__] but she's got giant
tears
those beats are so on point check this
out check this out
a body like Melody's kind of cool on
this one
[Music]
is so gross have you ever met a girl
every every [__] song is the same
they're all the same it's so it's so
cool all right well to play devil's
advocate here and for his sake couldn't
you argue that every song in the 80s was
the same too
same premise same plot same style I
don't know I'm not a music biographer
what type of music are you like hair
metal yeah specifically is awful too my
point yeah yeah
I don't know it's like the first line is
she's this but she's that which is
contradiction so this is the story of a
girl making memories
[Music]
oh damn the Uber block yo this guy balls
hard
he just flecks with the Uber black he
definitely has three stars on Uber too
I'm gonna catch a case
I'm pre-gaming that's a very creepy
story
yes hmm
eight shots and I'm holding her hair
back
10 shots I'm getting it out the Rope
12 shots I'm opening the basement Cellar
Door
14 shots I've got her on the radiator
16 shots her mom is calling me asking me
if I know where she is
[Music]
18 shots and then please come to my
house 20 shots I tell them I don't know
where she is 22 shots they say you're
the last person that saw her 24 Shots I
said don't go in the basement
fire he's cool though I I don't want to
give him too much [__] sometimes he
tells a story beforehand he does a
little skit instead of just a little
intro oh yeah 5c is one of them this
one's her villain all right so this
right here is for any girl that's just
hot enough bro Reddit song about a dude
man
you know why do the girls get all their
songs
for any girl that's just hot enough and
yeah
that's it she just had a really bad day
she's ready to become a villain she's a
bad day and she's ready to be a villain
[Music]
yes
his sister
[Music]
all right so yo
look I'll give it to this guy he's
trying he has a good voice yeah he's
trying he's putting himself out there
yeah he
you got to take risks and he's right why
is it the shortest girls have the
biggest attitude I'm trying to say I
have noticed that
this one I've been saying that yeah no I
know you do always say that it's nice
when someone backs you up finally
I'd do anything to be with her
she's a sad girl oh she's a sad girl
wait what's this song about
I know I know it's she's sad but she's
pretty no no I thought it was a happy
girl who's not photogenic yeah wait
oh [__] see I should have done the intro
to be more clear yeah okay Bryce
you got how [__] tall she is yeah
like how big or small is her attitude
yeah
is she a bad chick like on a height
scale is she a five six is your five
eight attitude she's five eleven
attitude right
look at there here's the top comment
could you do a song about a girl who's
scared to be herself because of her past
hmm that's a good one because of her
p-a-s-s-e-doh
it's a scared girl who's afraid of her
her past
laughs
she's a sad girl with the prettiest
pictures
[Music]
it is a sad world
that's really sweet with pretty pictures
so she looks good in pictures but she's
beat in real life no he said she looks
Pretty in Pink and she looks pretty in
Black which I think is kind and nice but
why does he say he's what does he say
she's a sad girl we got that yeah but
then she's pretty in pictures
like he makes that he makes that
distinction the only in pictures
normally does she look pretty well lucky
did he get catfished she's a sad girl
but she looks pretty in pictures
supposed to be like but she looks happy
in photos or is he just saying she's sad
but she's hot that he's trying to say
she's had she's sad but she's hot but I
think it even goes deeper she's sad I
thought she was hot but then when I met
up with her she wasn't hot she only
lives so she's actually so she's sad and
ugly right which as you know
is the worst right
if you're going to be sad you might as
well be hot about it so true
I do anything to be with her
anything bro
she's a sad girl
it's just
it's pretty interesting
you know and again
great guy
love him I sent love the husband of the
storyline ones okay thank you here we
got a whole story this is what I'm the
more talking the better in my opinion
that's why I'm here
Jesus said girl Yeah scratch it dude all
right I'm gonna get the session set up
bro my girl just dumped me over text no
way wait what she said I played too many
video games and that'll never be a real
musician yeah didn't you guys date for
like two years
yep dude I am sorry maybe you should
just take the day off hell yeah hit
record I got something I gotta say yeah
yeah
[Music]
I think he's a virgin
I think he's he's in an Intel what
[Music]
yeah I hate you yeah I mean he's really
versatile I love him playing the role of
someone listening to his music and
loving it
that's like when fresh and fit hit their
own sound bites it was cool when when
the producer character that he's playing
knew the lyrics of the song that he was
singing was already sing along
I said one about anxiety a girl with
anxiety okay that's relatable yeah I
like that thank you I hope he says that
he does how you figured that out yeah
you have to read between the lines what
subtext yeah a girl whose mind races at
night playing a constant Loop of
everything that causes her anxiety oh
bro can you why is it going to be about
a girl
that's what every again parallel with
the 80s music oh stop it dude come on
let let her out you're talking about
yourself man just let her out
oh interesting move of everything that
causes her anxiety oh yeah he's talking
about himself [__] kind of dances at
night playing a constant Loop of
everything that causes her anxiety so
interesting
you're so right yeah I feel like it
would be his music would be a lot more
personal if he just said you know when
you're laying in bed and your thoughts
are racing at night yeah it's about him
why why you got to project it all into
some girl that's you know never gonna
[__] you anyway and maybe even sleeping
soundly who knows
can we peep the hashtags real quick
hashtag sad song hashtag sad hashtag
mental health hashtag mental health
awareness hashtag poetry hashtag sad
poetry hashtag sad lyrics hashtag
alternative hashtag emo okay I know
we're all uh searching up hashtag sad
lyrics all the time this is a song about
hashtags by the way props I mean this
this has a hundred thousand likes so
wow so this is the story of a girl whose
mind races at night playing a concert
it's a very clear voice I will say
he's a hunk
I'd [__] him no he [__]
but he gives me the vibe of like you
think he does but his game is so bad he
just creeps and weirds out every girl
and repels them that's what I'm getting
he definitely brings up his music and
every conversation for sure dude I don't
think women like him I think he's I
think he's a repellent I've met dudes
like him uh of course I don't know
anything about you though you're the
best
I mean you're the best dude really is
this the story of a girl where
everyone's first impression of her is
that she's really innocent didn't we
already hear this one when you get to
actually talking to her you find out
she's kind of got a dirty mind
oh okay it's a different intro though
[Music]
all right I remember when we set this
one up
yeah he's the man I like him I don't
know I'm not trying to be a hater it
just it just really blew me away when I
saw it here if Putin starts world war
three if Putin starts world war three
it's gonna be my theme song
[Music]
no you guys are gonna die too
what do you know well there you go
that's the song's not about a girl yeah
there you go it is it's about if
everybody dies it's me and you alive
oh it's still about a girl
I just want to know how they were able
to survive
we need us we need enough to know well
maybe it's in the second verse starts
world war three this is gonna be my
theme song
[Music]
okay it's giving Patrice
said there but he spelled it it is
giving me Patrice Wilson's verse on
Friday yeah
okay
we love them
just something that came up
you got that
innocent oh this is his Bob
that's my favorite one
that's a signature to him
[Music]
my favorite is when he says literally
the exact thing he set it up with it's
so cool
so there it is uh he but he's doing good
he's doing great yeah he's doing good
he's on Tick Tock too his Spotify number
he's got like over 600 000 followers on
them there you go Bryce Savage
my wife
[Applause]
married
and actually all back you were calling
him an insect I take it all back woman
repellent take it all back
his wife also sounds like has a child
from another marriage so that's a huge
thing for him stepping up like that
so good for him he's a good man yeah
Bryce is a good man
hear me out oh
so my wife was a single mother before we
met obviously she isn't anymore but for
Mother's Day I wrote her do you like how
he bounces like look how he's bouncing
his feet yeah so my wife was a single
mother before we met him
I wrote her something that has a message
that is not only for her but for any
single mom that's out there working hard
to make ends okay so I posted a snippet
of this message in a song and a ton of
people used it as a sound over the
weekend and just shared it and really
resonated with the message so this one
goes out to my wife in the past when she
was struggling I hope you all enjoyed
Mother's Day and keep raising good
people because the world needs them okay
[Music]
you think um
first half of that video was touching
not the second half
you think his wife likes his music
yes yeah probably
yeah I'm kidding she's probably
supported she's number one fan she
doesn't give him any lips she is like
well over 60. she's like seven too she's
the chillest woman she's the Everman
she's the tallest woman that ever lived
I disagree she's five five and She
[__] hates it
[Music]
different attitude she's got a lot of
things this one's about him being a
Pisces dude oh [__]
[Music]
oh no she's a Pisces
baby
[Music]
these songs have the same chord
progression just shift to a different
key dude they're all the [__] same
song He's like dressed the same the song
is the same the it's CR it's wild it's
just like it's incredible this genre
he's branded himself absolutely when I
hear a Bryce Savage I know it's a Bryce
Savage
yep I only date Pisces
whatever that means I'm a Pisces just
saying I can do it I knew I had a
feeling brother me and you
she's a sad girl with the prettiest
pictures all right so that's it so thank
you Bryce uh we do love you got a Bryce
oh we have a picture of him and his wife
is this from social media I can show
this
yeah social media Instagram is it where
to pull this up or fine I mean they look
happy not like in a bad way
what does that mean in a bat no I said
it's not in a bad way they're just happy
it's at their at their wedding they just
look happy yeah I mean it's yeah he's a
he's a she's a public figure
I think it's relevant because he's yeah
they look happy
and she looks his age right yeah age
appropriate very cute love them
I love that he wrote her a beautiful
song for Mother's Day me too that is
very that's nice yeah you know it's kind
of hard to tell but he looks fairly tall
like
she's in Flash she's bending her feet
probably yeah she's kind of bent
slightly so so she sometimes the women
do that in the picture because they
don't want to dominate their man right
so she's kind of making herself shorter
for his benefit because he's got she's
got no attitude about it does that mean
he's adult she's a tall queen or is that
only applicable to women
what is he a dick because he's short
does he have no attitude yeah
judgment on their height around here
he's little and he has a little dick
don't we don't know
I was that wasn't about him
no that was about the Royal hymn
uh Royal he
so then there's other ones actually
because I was like is this this is a
whole genre apparently
I don't know what kind of music you call
this but there's another guy who's
crushing it X to official
and I'll say this guy in my opinion
xxxtentacion this guy gets more of a
pass from me just because he's younger
he's like 23 or 22. 22. we're not sure
exactly what that's what we saw on
Google so but but he's definitely on the
train of uh
what are we dubbing this genre
um
artists that explain their lyrics in
great detail yeah e-boy so here he is
this guy's got it or you listen to sad
songs to feel happy and all of your
favorite singers are mentally ill and
scream in pain here's your daily dose of
Serotonin just moved
so I like that he explains it more
[Music]
I'm not even gonna joke on this he's 22.
he's out there crushing it you know what
I mean I mean the other dude's 33. my
kids you know
it's like Kidz Bop you can't Kids Bop at
33. no this one not gonna lie we were
jamming out to him number three
specifically we we were singing all
morning lyrics start with I'm a 5'4 man
[__] uh oh this one's my favorite
you're even shorter than his short girl
I wonder if he is actually 4-4
five four I'm four five four sorry sorry
[Music]
no I just wasn't expecting that line
very important to this genre to say
Heights
bro I'm not even gonna hate this this is
better than the last guys without a
doubt yeah it's better than the last
guys oh this [__] and he's younger
five four man [__] I don't like that he
flexes how many kids like him though I
don't like that he flexed that he tried
to kill himself
seemed like a flex
like listeners
it's like dope it's not cool it's not
like it's not dope like that's not like
cool
though
[Music]
so that's tx2 official who um
people like despite him cutting his
wrists well he he uses hashtag emo
oh I need to start all those tagging all
of ourselves hashtag mentally ill and
maybe his art is his way of healing who
who's to say right and people can find
like I'm a former emo kid you can find
catharsis through seeing other people
share your suffering and stuff but as an
adult definitely this is very goofy I
got no problem with this dude this guy's
crushing it I got this guy's the man
okay now just imagine he's making the
same music
in 11 years you gotta there's a certain
point where you need to evolve a little
bit as an artist right but I'm feeling
I'm feeling TX too official just don't
glorify yourself
that's not a good you know don't yeah
that's not let off that stuff I wasn't
feeling that too much
bro are you doing it again let's go wait
what is
put a bullet in that kid's head oh let
me
[Music]
in the garage
in the flag of the USA
[Applause]
[Music]
okay kind of based actually I'm very
pissed yo this is the Gen Z that we need
taking over he just called out all these
closeted
dude this is a Vibe Dan it's a vibe that
was good kids
[Music]
that's actually kind of poignant
that's kind of pointy yeah that is kind
of hitting yeah
he's right
my boys got a point if you okay you can
see that it's white text or the black
text with white background there gives
more context too like go to the start of
the video again okay
[__] religion
so which party were you talking about
this is a message to the governor oh man
you spell You misspelled Governors like
really bad he's trying wait wait
ignores wait a little the phone brother
they're his best man this part's in the
right place listen I'm not a great
Spiller but I haven't smelled Governors
that bad since I was in like third grade
this is a message to the governors
who are Banning drag shows in public
spaces and access to healthcare for
anyone trans under 18. I'm with you
brother absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
name this song Randy McNally after the
governor governor is he doing that on
purpose I was curious if he thinks he's
going to be suppressed if he writes
Governor why would he be stress
spreading Governor I don't know but he
has other things change the writing of
some other things Governor I did it
twice I can't see any reason to do that
other than misspelling it well we
misspelled Tennessee too
yeah you know what the lyrics are good I
like it
he says go watch it in my profile
okay he so he does have some interesting
Styles he does profile with a one for
the I
but if you have what do you think this
is 2003 is so back
we are so back baby
bring back Myspace and get it over with
dude I'm feeling TX too
well that's a
lot
[Music]
okay but there it is and but then we go
back uh to the original I was trying to
think like who's the king of this genre
is it Bryce
because Bryce has the most following so
far but then you go back
all the way
and you find this dude uh
where's that dude oh here social repose
now I don't know anything about this guy
that he was dating Trisha's sister when
I was
in their life
and I was like
interesting life choice
I mean no offense
you know
he takes that five percent
I mean you know
so
so uh so check this guy out I get a lot
of people know who he is I'm not super
familiar but he's he's got a wild outfit
he gets down in
um here he is on a park bench
wait he dropped a song with the n-word
in it which is pretty hard no that's not
him oh different guy oh it's here
okay on my bad social repos I'm talking
about someone else
uh he has not dropped the song with the
n-word but where's the video here I want
to see him rock out
I sent this chord
I keep thinking can we are you gonna
watch the video
uh where is it it was sent and Discord
God damn
[Music]
okay
this man's straight up owns that bench
[Music]
I really [__] it up
enough time
deny my dear
gotta say you've got a voice on him
no I can't tell it sounds like it's
studio recorded which yeah I think it's
lip syncing too yeah and those are fake
water sound effects yeah yes so so then
yeah it's not even the original audio it
looks it you could tell the sound just
isn't it doesn't feel right is that him
singing that song
huh people use that as like a as a sound
on Tick Tock oh yeah that's him
Dark Souls armor
yeah he's giving me I don't know man
this this is a lot for me there's a
headdress it's giving like Native
American
uh is this cultural appropriation I mean
it looks like it constantly gets
canceled for that but he's on Native
American land I can tell you you know
what I mean he's out there tap dancing
on their graves
tap dancing on a bench in a Native
American burial ground have we
considered he might be a ghost
and this is a ghost that's interesting
Theory
he's definitely lip sync my dad
yeah if it can't be easy to put together
though I'll tell you man
and he's been doing that for years yeah
10 12 years my name is Richie from
social Repose and I've avoided making
this video for a very long time about a
year ago I just so why wearing a
headdress is okay so uh this is actually
a conversation that's been happening
apparently decided to put on this
headdress and kind of make it part of my
brand and obviously
it's ruffled a lot of feathers okay
literally this video I I gotta not I
gotta not make the jokes and obviously
when I put it on I knew I was gonna get
a lot of backlash and even to this day I
still get a lot of messages oh [__] a
lot of hate it's probably the source of
most of my hate on YouTube you went
there Facebook and all that just the
occasional person coming in saying hey
did you know that's offensive and I'm
offended come on dude don't hit me with
me like that we're on educated views are
coming from I get it and I'm making this
video to kind of explain where I'm
coming from and why I'm not a terrible
racist person and My reasonings for
wearing the headdress and deciding that
it's okay now in this video I'm going to
be sweeping over just pretty much the
main argument that like 98 of people
come at me with
um which is are you Native American and
if you're not the headdress is reserved
for war heroes or higher up what about
this or essentially people that have
earned the right to wear it within their
tribe that's generally the main argument
that I am presented with a lot of people
that are of Native American descents
um or people that are just generally
offended um because they enjoy being
offended at things so before I address
this multi-part argument
um I have a little bit of a story
um I don't care what's your argument
here here's the most watched part
Dennis Prager
thing one is better than the other they
are just very different which can be
explained in the article below um it's
it's pretty complicated and the
differences but you can read about it
and it makes a lot of sense comparing me
to wearing someone with a traditional
Native American headdress is like
comparing someone who is wearing the
Medal of Honor to someone who went to a
gift shop that bought a metal whatever
you know good for him I guess uh he's
he's very unique
oh look at this a little mbop I'm smile
fades in the summer a little [__] new
age
[Applause]
they need to be moving as a unit right
okay we love it
he's out there like Sasquatch what is
with him standing on benches I gotta ask
BFF
Wake Me Up Inside
okay okay social repos so I don't know
but here's my fave this dude uh this
would be the last one but this one's
really good you guys
oh where'd it go
here's an old school one this dude uh
pup is on puppies
by J Bigga
and he straight up drops the n-word in
it and it's so wild dude it's [__]
wild
as high as you can if she's worth it
break her down and leave her for Dad if
she is
all that you want isn't real
really
[Music]
wow dude what the [__] if that face
looks at you offering you puppies you
[__] run dude puppies in your what
um
[Music]
okay anyway just to give you a taste and
then the most watched part
right here it's so out of pocket
[Music]
it's like like for one reason dude why
did you have to drop and bombs like no
reason dude whoa that's awesome
[__]
yeah
um
pretty bold choice
you know
what's next wearing a headdress
what was the role of Tony dracita N word
love
right it roll out tonight yeah I dropped
in what's happening that that was crazy
roller Tony Brown town
yeah yeah
I don't remember seeing that and
everyone kind of looks around what's
that this morning but because it's
awkward whoa Lawrence I got I got red
pill four
the legend uh John Fitch who's gonna
tell me how to choke a [__] out
oh dude yeah was this recent
yeah it looks like it this just did this
just happen
look at the meeting of mine four days
ago yeah you can kind of see people
being a little bit taken aback of a
little bit people are like what the [__]
genuinely shocked yeah how to Chuck a
[__] out
this guy this is the only guy who's like
what the fridge Rolo Tony man your age
is showing brother
and your racism when you were a kid
there probably was just straight up like
slavery or
yeah something like that 200.
so
oh yes that is so painful that's so
Glenn Lawrence I got I got red pill four
I got rides
destroy and I have Demand with the
legend uh John Fitch who's gonna tell me
how to choke a [__] out
yikes yeah
that's a rough one roll up Tony the
double laughter he becomes quiet and
then starts laughing again later he's a
good man we like roller Tommy no we
don't hate Rolo
he means well
all right right
right he doesn't all right well this has
been a weird episode but I think it's
time to go off the rails baby
so um tomorrow is leftovers
we're back
Friday is after dark tomorrow the
classics collections dropping hope you
guys all enjoy that and uh thanks
everyone for watching see you tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]